Hello everybody, what are you guys talking about?
The intro has been looped like three times already, guys.
What do you mean?
You guys saw it.
You guys saw the emotes, the guitar.
I saw the guitar emotes and the clapping to the intro.
What are you talking about?
It's been, it's been looping.
Oh, yeah, right.
It was four times.
That was on you guys.
It was on me.
All right.
I'll tell you guys a story.
Today.
So the member goons, you already heard the story, but I'll tell them why.
I'll tell them why I was very, I was very sleep-deprived.
I still am a little.
All right, so story time.
For those who don't have members, I will be telling you a story that the member goons have already heard, but I'll be retelling it.
So, um, today, last night, had to be one of the worst hour, like worse sleep I've ever had in my life.
It was actually terrible.
Like, because Doki Amberdoge's dad here, decided that he was like, I'm gonna wake this bitch up four to, not even four, six to seven times throughout the night.
For no reason.
No reason!
NO REASON AT ALL!
So you guys might be wondering, why was he waking me up 6-7 times throughout the night?
Well, yesterday, for the very first time...
Not the very first, I got a babysitter.
Like a new babysitter for him.
Because yesterday, I wanted to go to the fair.
To the local fair.
And I found this new babysitter.
Like this is the very first time I used a babysitter.
I used this particular babysitter.
She had really good credentials and everything.
And the reason why I didn't take him to a normal daycare...
Was because...
He does not have his vaccines up to date.
So like the daycare needed him to have the kennel cough vaccination up to date.
And obviously...
Well, not obviously.
That's not me.
I...
The kennel cough vaccination has expired for him.
And I actually tried to...
I tried to book an early...
I tried to book a vet appointment a week and a half ago.
But literally, the earliest time that the vet could take me in was September 4th, by the way.
It was September 4th was the earliest that he could...
That the vet could take dad in for his shots.
And I didn't have that time.
Like I couldn't...
I didn't have that time.
And...
Basically...
So I had to get like a personal babysitter.
It was very expensive, by the way.
It was very expensive.
And I got a personal babysitter for him.
And...
I don't know what the fuck she and her husband did.
But when he came back...
He was so...
I don't...
He was so spoiled.
Like...
She...
She did...
Too good of a job.
She did way too good of a job.
Because...
Because when I got him back...
When I fucking got this guy back...
Like...
Oh my god.
I was like, it's sleep time.
Because basically the babysitter took care of him from 9 a.m.
to 9 p.m.
And so...
I was tired.
I was tired from the fair.
And so I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go head to bed.
I pet him.
I cuddle him.
And I was like...
Alright, it's sleep time.
He gets to sleep on my bed.
It's not like I kicked him off my bed.
He gets to sleep in my bed.
And then so I was like...
It's sleep time.
But then...
When I got in bed...
He like jumped on the bed.
And he looked at the door.
And then started crying.
Like he started whining.
He's like...
And I was like...
What the fuck?
Like I've never heard that voice...
Like I've never heard that sound before.
I was like...
You've never done this before.
Never.
I've never heard him whine like this before.
And he's like...
Looking at me.
He was looking outside the door.
And then...
And then he like...
Jumped down the bed.
And walked...
And I just walked over to the door.
Like the outside door.
And he was like...
And he's like...
And then he walked...
And then he walked back into my room.
And then...
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Anyway...
I fell asleep one time...
Once...
When I fell...
The first time I fell back asleep...
He woke me up.
Because he started barking.
He started barking like...
And I was like...
What...
What do you want?
I was like...
And then...
And then he just like...
He just...
He like...
Gets down.
And then...
Gets...
Walks out of my room.
And then I just...
Heard like...
The pitter patter.
The pitter patter of his like...
Feet on the wooden floor.
And I just...
He's just walking around.
He's just walking around the floor.
And then he...
He went back.
He went back to my bed.
And then...
Stopped barking.
And he did this six to seven times.
At one point I just closed the door.
I closed the door.
And then he woke me up.
And started barking at the door.
I was like...
Open the door.
And I was like...
What?
Usually...
When I had...
To sleep.
He goes to sleep.
Instantly.
With me.
He...
He goes to sleep.
Instantly.
With me.
And...
But this time...
This time...
He wouldn't stop.
He wouldn't...
I...
I tried to ignore him.
But then...
It was also really late at night.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
And then...
And then he finally...
Like...
I...
At eight a.m.
I couldn't take it anymore.
He woke me up so many times.
And then...
At eight a.m.
He was like...
Now it's time to walk me.
And I was like...
What the fuck?
Like...
He usually never demands this from me.
I was so surprised.
Usually he would never demand walkies or food.
Or feeding time.
Like...
He and I have an understanding.
Where like...
I'm very busy.
So he and I...
We have an understanding.
Where...
We...
He would get walkies and food around eight a.m.
Like...
Those were the hours.
He would never demand what time the walkies and foods are.
He would sleep with me until it was time for me to get up.
And I was like...
It's walking time.
It's feeding time.
He would...
He would be going by my schedule.
Not by his own.
And today...
This morning...
He demanded that I walked him and feed him at eight a.m.
And I was like...
He...
He was...
He was very demanding.
And at that point...
And then when I did his walkies...
And his...
When I did his walkies right after...
He was like...
Alright.
I'm done.
I'm okay now.
And then he falls straight...
He falls asleep right away.
Because I was like...
I can't.
I need a nap.
I'm so tired.
And then he never woke me up.
He never woke me up.
My alarm woke me up at twelve p.m.
He didn't wake me up once.
And I was like...
He just was like, all right, sleep time.
Still, sleep time.
Okay,
it was sleep time.
Now you're okay.
Oh my god.
And then...
Okay, I showed this photo during the member stream.
I showed this photo and I was like, okay, that makes sense why he's like this now.
Let me show you guys the photo.
This is basically one of the photos the babysitter sent me of like, how fucking spoiled he was.
Like, look at this.
He's just like, bring me back.
I was like, okay, I understand.
I understand.
And then today, this is right after the member stream, by the way.
This is right after the member stream.
Today, today, I was like, I had to get food.
This is also why I was late.
I was finishing up eating my dinner.
I didn't have lunch, by the way.
I need you guys to know I didn't have lunch, so this was like my first meal.
So, this was right after.
I had my food at like, around like, I had my first meal at around like, 5 40.
So, the thing is, I went downstairs to pick up my food.
Right?
So like, um, the thing is, dad would have never whined about, it was so, okay, I like, I went to open my door to go downstairs, right?
And then dad instantly jumped down from the bed, and then went up to the door, and the moment I closed the door, I hear him crying.
He was like, oh, the
door!
And I was like, what the fuck?
We've done this before!
Why are you crying?
Why?
You've seen me walk downstairs and cry before.
What happened?
One day, I leave you alone for one day.
Why?
What happened?
Like, what happened in the span of one day?
Like, it wasn't even a full night.
It wasn't even, like, I went down, I literally could hear him while I was waiting at the elevator.
I heard him while I was waiting at the elevator.
And all I could hear was, oh, oh.
I was like, why?
You know I'm coming back!
I'm just getting food!
And
hours!
I'm literally getting food!
But yes, anyway, so, and then, like, I came back up from the food and he was still, I don't hear the crying anymore.
I just see him at the door.
Like, he was just at the doorstep just waiting for me.
And I was like, what?
What happened?
I've left before, even at the old apartment!
Like, I had to get food before.
He would never, he would be like, whenever I had to get food at my old apartment, he didn't give a fuck.
He did not care.
He just slept.
He just would be like, oh, she's out to get food?
Let me stay in my fucking bed and sleep.
And then when I have the food, he's just like, oh, there's your food.
Let me keep on sleeping!
.
I was like, holy shit.
What the fuck happened to you?
.
He was finally shown love.
Anyway, so I made, like, a comparison.
Basically, it's like, basically, dad is like the lonely housewife for wine.
I am the overworked husband that's just trying to make money for us to survive.
And the babysitter is the pool boy.
.
I'm just like, please, I'm just trying to work.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, dad.
I'm just trying to work so that you can have food on the table.
I'm trying.
You need to let me sleep.
And you want me to keep working.
Anyway, that's, like, life update right now.
That's the life update for him.
Yeah, so, like, I'm definitely not gonna use this babysitter very often now.
And, like, for very, very, very rare occasion.
After this fucker gets his kennel cough vaccine, I'm fucking sticking him to the daycare if I need somebody to look after him.
I'm putting him in the doggy daycare.
It's cheaper and also, like, he does not He does not demand things from me right after.
No!
Don't take this away from him!
This is where he feels at!
No, no, no.
We cannot.
I need to sleep, guys.
I...
I need to fuck...
Oh, yeah!
By the way, when we got...
When I got, like, um, uh, dad back, uh, when I got dad back, picked him up from the babysitter, I was like, how is he?
And then the babysitter was like, oh, he loves attention.
And I was like, yeah, yeah, I can see that.
Like, you know, I, like, glossed over the fact because I was like, yeah, he does.
He sort of does love attention.
But I didn't realize how much attention that the sitter gave him.
Like, I did not realize!
I just, like, glossed over it because I was like, that sounds right.
Yeah, like, he does.
He does like it when he, you know, he does like cuddling in bed.
So, like, yeah.
And then now I realize what she meant when she said, he loves attention.
Um, so yeah, that is life update for this fucker.
Also, um, I won't talk too long about uh, the some, if you want to know more story about how my life was like at the fair, that it would be a member exclusive story because, uh, it took me 48 minutes to tell that story.
And, like, I don't want to spend another 48 minutes telling the story about the fair.
So, unless you ask me about the story at the convention, I'll tell you the story about the fair story at the convention if I'm there.
Okay, guys?
If I'm there, I'll tell it to you.
Also, did you guys know Mihoyo made a fucking nuclear reactor?
I just wanted to, this is like off-topic about everything, but, like, uh, I really, I Did you guys see that?
Yeah!
Yeah, the company that makes Genshin Impact and, like, um, there's a ZZZ and um, yeah, they made a nuclear reactor.
No, like, in real life, not fucking in game.
They literally made a nuclear reactor in real life and I was like, holy f- yeah, I was like
I saw, I read an article about it and I was cause, like, there's this whole meme about, um, oh yeah, they sponsored a reactor.
They, like, this is still fucking crazy to think about.
Here's the article.
It, like, showed up on my Twitter.
Um, they've officially had too much money.
Like, literally gotcha money has sponsored a nuclear reactor.
That's when you know, um, that's when you know they might have a bit too much money.
Yeah, it's apparently for the environment but that's still the craziest shit I've ever read, like, yesterday.
They're like, yeah, Mio, you fucking sponsored a nuclear react- I think they sponsored, like, the space program in China, too, I think.
I'm not that- don't quote me on that.
But, like, I saw somebody mention that, too, and I was like, what?
They- They sponsored a space journey?
Like, whoa!
Jesus!
Um...
Yeah, today's reactor is sponsored, uh, by- That was a different- a different guy- okay, the fact that, like, it's also a, um, that a gacha game- like, there- there's enough gacha games there's enough gacha money to the point that, like, a different gacha game sponsored a space program.
That is wild.
I should make a gacha- I can't imagine if I made a gacha game.
That's-
Holy shit, maybe then I can sponsor a nuclear reactor that's just for me.
Um...
Let's see...
Alright.
Thank you.
Anyway, I don't know if today my PC- if my PC decides to explode again for, um, and we don't- we're not gonna go to the hub area, but if my PC decides to fucking explode again today, um, I'm gonna- I'll take it to the shop.
I'll take it to the shop.
Um, or- okay, so, actually, Hyatt actually reached out asking, like, if they could help with anything.
I might ask if they could just- if I could get, like, another PC and then do a- do a- finally!
Do a dual PC setup because this is rea- I don't know how.
I don't know how I- I can...
I'm this cursed when it comes to PC.
Like, I- I don't know.
I just- I don't know anymore.
I'm just forever cursed.
Like, it's just- life is just like that.
I've, like, accepted my, um, I've accepted my destiny.
I'm just cursed to forever have PC issues.
Like, nothing- nothing can save me.
If a- if two PCs cannot save me, then, like, it's over.
It's actually over.
Alright.
Um, but yes.
I don't - I don't even know where I was at.
I was so mad about the whole PC stuff that, like, I don't...
How?
Let's see.
How am I?
How- How am I not?
Like, that crash fucked my PC so much that it's never been the same.
It's never been the same.
I don't- the thing is, I don't know what it did.
I don't know.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
Okay.
I don't know what I did.
Let me see.
Whatever happened that day.
Whatever happened that day, it was never the same.
It was never the same.
Okay, we're gonna figure this out, guys.
We're gonna figure this out together.
Like, we can figure this out together, guys.
I- I believe.
I fucking believe.
Like, okay, the worst part- Let me tell you guys.
The worst part is that my CPU and my memory is okay.
Like, I- It's okay.
That's the thing.
That's the worst part.
Like, it's okay.
Like, How is that- How is that possible?
How- Like, it's not even- It's not like 70%.
It's not like it's on 100.
That's the thing.
It's not like it's at 100%.
How is this possible?
Okay.
What the fuck?
What happened?
What happened to you ever since that crash?
You've changed.
Oh, God.
Ever since the crash.
Ever since the crash of 24.
And something happened to you.
Okay.
I have an idea.
I know what to do, guys.
I'm not- Oh, God.
You changed.
Alright.
Frame generation.
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna turn off frame.
Generation.
Alright.
Here we go.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe.
Okay.
I have an idea.
I have an idea, guys.
I know what to do.
I'm gonna disappear for a sec.
I have an idea.
Chat.
This is- I know what to do, guys.
I know what to do.
I know exactly what to do.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Manage.
Okay.
Where are you?
How do I start?
I can do this.
There's no way.
This game will not win over me.
I don't know what happened.
Ever since the crash of 24.
Nothing's been the same since the crash of 24.
Okay.
I'll figure this out.
I know what to do, guys.
I figured it out, guys.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Guys.
I figured it out.
I know what to do.
Okay.
Where the fuck is it?
Guys.
Ignore when I said that, guys.
I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
I said, where the fuck is it?
I don't mean it.
I know exactly what I'm doing.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
This should be it.
Alright.
Here we go.
We can do this.
Alright.
I'm back.
Here we go.
There's no way.
There is no way.
Like, what happened to you?
Like...
This is a crash!
You've never been the same!
We're figuring this out, guys.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
There's no way.
There's actually no way.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh my gosh.
Is my Nvidia control settings okay?
Let's see.
Am I supposed to have G-Sync, by the way, guys?
Guys, I don't know if I'm supposed to have G-Sync on, guys.
Am I supposed to have G-Sync on?
Yes?
Okay.
No?
Yes.
Okay.
Alright.
That's good enough.
I think.
Where are the settings?
Okay.
I have G-Sync on.
Yes.
Okay.
Guys, this is like tech support.
But like, live.
Let's just have live tech support.
What's the worst that could happen?
Okay.
Continue training.
Alright.
Here we go.
Someone said I should lower super resolution to 60%.
Should I do that?
You are my tech support now.
Don't worry.
The gaming part will be ready soon.
Ready soon.
Alright.
Oh my god.
What happened to you?
Oh god.
Alright.
Okay.
60%.
Alright.
Apply.
Yes.
Okay.
Maybe that's it.
Alright.
Is there anything we can like turn down?
We don't need shadows, right?
Okay.
Shadows.
Medium.
That's fine.
Hair quality.
Okay.
You know what?
We don't need good reflections.
Like, that's fine.
Global.
I don't even know what that even means.
I don't want to turn down vegetation.
But I want to look at the grass better.
I want...
I want to look down the grass.
But I want the grass to look better.
Oh my god.
We fixed it.
Wait.
Is it...
Did we fix it?
Oh my god.
Everything...
We did it.
Look.
I don't want to touch grass again.
So I need to live vicariously through.
Oh my god.
We fixed it.
We did it.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Let's get home.
Alright.
It's okay.
That's all it took, guys.
Alright.
Where should we go?
I know I went here because I was very frustrated and just kept going forward.
Oh my god, everybody.
We fucking did it.
We're not gonna fight the tiger!
The tiger fucking made my PC explode.
I mean, there's so many monkeys.
Not white.
And my PC crashes again after we fight the tiger.
I swear to fucking god.
I...
This is not fair!
I was trying to talk to my chat!
Okay.
Nice.
You think I care that you're blocking?
Oh, maybe I do care.
Oh shit.
I did not mean to do this.
Okay.
That's fine.
Monkey friends!
Go forth!
Alright.
Nice.
Go monkeys!
Do your monkey things!
Oh no.
My monkeys are dying.
It's fine.
Monkeys are frozen!
Monkeys!
Do your monkey thing!
Wait.
Is he dead?
Did I do it?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
What did I do?
What was that?
Is he gone?
Wait.
That was it?
What?
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna go get my magic back.
Like what the fuck?
What's the point?
I'm just gonna get my magic back at this point.
He ran away so like I can reset my magic.
Alright.
See?
He's not gonna fight me again.
He's a fucking coward.
There's...
He lost the one and...
He won and done.
Imagine losing and then try...
You're supposed to one and done when you win!
Losing with a one and done doesn't...
Oh this is really cool.
Losing in a one and done doesn't put the same message out.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh these guys are dead dead.
They give me will?
Oh they do.
So I might as well kill it.
Alright.
Nice.
Here we go.
Oh!
It's a blind guy.
It's fine.
I can kill him.
Woo!
What's he gonna do?
Kick me?
I can't even see!
Oh!
He has his brother.
They were blind.
They were genetically disposed...
Genetically disposed to be blind.
It's fine.
English hard.
Alright.
Let's see.
Poke!
Nice.
Guys.
As long as you understand what I'm saying that's all that matters.
I might not be saying it correctly.
But you understood.
Alright.
Let's see.
Forward we go.
There's so many of these guys.
Like.
Why are they guarding this area?
Oh!
Shit!
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Come on!
Get out of here!
I need to finish Chapter 3!
If it's the last thing I do.
I just need to finish Chapter 3.
I've been stuck in this chapter for so long.
Please.
I just wanna know what it's like at the end of the tunnel.
Alright.
Nice.
Poke!
Alright.
Guys.
I haven't learned Street Fighter yet.
Hahaha!
I just want you guys to know.
Alright.
There you go.
I will eventually!
Just like how I mastered King!
I learned King one very late last moment.
Hahaha!
It will happen eventually.
Alright.
Has there been any issues on stream guys?
I can't tell I'm very focused.
Alright.
And so far, that's good to know.
Maybe it's this area.
Maybe it's just this area.
Hahaha!
And so far so good.
Alright.
That's good to know.
Oh there he is again!
Wait that's not fair!
He's full HP!
That's not fair!
That's cheating!
I say as I also rest up.
Whoa!
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah!
How can you heal?
Guys this is why I heal too.
Because I knew he was gonna heal as well.
Hahaha!
Yeah but like I'm literally the main character.
I should be allowed to heal.
He's not the main character.
He doesn't even have a game base off him.
Oh no I'm frozen.
Oh I'm so slow!
Wow!
Oh no.
That's fine.
Oh no!
I'm recharging as much as I can!
Oh!
Please let me poke you!
It's not fair!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Heal.
That's fine.
I poked him a little bit.
The moment I'm out of this, it's over for you!
What?!
What the fuck is this
thing?!
What the fuck is this thing?!
Is that poison?
What is he doing?
That's it.
No more Mr. Nice Monkey.
Wait.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
GO OTHER MONKEYS!
GO!
Please!
He's right there!
Just hit him!
Please!
Oh god.
Just hit him!
Other me's!
He's so low!
Oh god.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm gonna be greedy!
I'm gonna be greedy.
I'm gonna be- YES!
Yes.
Greed has won yet again!
That's right!
I have greeded!
I knew greed would always work.
Blood of the Iron- Oh!
Is he like one of the the general people?
Non-white.
Okay.
What does that do?
Alright.
Time to meditate.
I hope my PC doesn't explode.
That's all I want.
Really it.
I only want one thing.
I still don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened.
Everything was okay until the crash of 24.
I never had a chance to fight it.
Zero issues.
And then that one crash destroyed everything.
Like, what happened?
I still don't understand.
I don't understand what happened.
Everything was good until that one... that day.
It just stopped being good.
Oh my god.
It just stopped.
Just stopped all of a sudden.
Like, we had zero issues before.
How did it just suddenly stop?
Alright, hero's life.
Oh hey, him again.
Didn't I already beat him up before?
Val?
You have S to C.
Okay.
Down I go.
Down down down I go.
The PC lived in peace until they crashed into the cat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Orin.
I'll never know what happened.
Like, I wasn't lagging.
Everybody was having a good time.
And then... and then suddenly... suddenly?
It just stopped?
Stopped?
Ever since the tiger, nothing has worked.
Let's go grab the shrine first before we do anything.
I need like $45,000 to upgrade my staff.
Alright, let's see.
Maybe I can now.
How much money do I have?
Oh, I do not.
What is the last question mark?
How do I even get that?
There's like a final question mark there, but I don't know how to get that.
Oh yeah, rest.
Oh, it's in Chapter 4?
God damn it.
I'm saving money for no reason.
Okay, let's go to the little hole first.
I don't know what the hole has.
Let me go into the hole.
That's the goal.
It's not unlocked yet?
Okay.
I thought it was like I need to find the area too.
Alright.
Wait, what the fuck?!
Where did you-
Bro!
Where the fuck did you come from?!
Oh my god, literally out of nowhere.
I was just like minding my own business.
Like, oh, that seems...
I wonder where this hole takes me.
This hole took me to a fucking boss fight.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Gotta heal.
That's right, get closer.
Oh!
Okay, not like that.
Not like that.
Not like that, Mr. Frog!
Oh!
No!
Please don't pour me!
Please!
Oh no!
Please Mr. Frog!
Oh Mr. Frog.
Oh my
god, it's Mr. Frog!
It is!
It's Mr. Frog!
Oh my god, Mr. Frogs game!
I can't believe it was the frog that killed me out of all the monsters the frog was the one that kills me i can't be lost in mr frog i'm mr frog i mean i'd vote for mr frog for president
It's understandable.
There we go.
Did I hit him?
I can't tell.
I can't tell sometimes.
Okay.
FIRE!
Oh my god.
Oh please.
FIRE!
Alright, that's enough fire for the day.
Oh shit!
No!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
Can't be that bad.
Okay, it can be.
Bro, what the fuck are his moves?
What can I do?
He just...
What can he... What are the fuck are his attacks?
Like, what do you do?
Bro, his AOE is an entire fucking map.
His AOE... Oh my god.
His AOE is a fucking entire map.
That's not fair.
I don't even have that big of an AOE.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
Jimmy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Sorry, I couldn't see what you said.
Ancient Lurker here.
You reminded me of how...
Haruka from FLCL a lot.
Recommended anime you haven't seen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have not seen a lot of anime in a while.
Bro, fuck this frog.
But like, don't fuck the frog.
But like, fuck this frog, though.
Like, actually.
I'm so mad, bro.
This frog...
This frog is like, difficult for no reason.
Like, I don't understand.
What is wrong with his AOE?
Like, he... he is like...
Okay, that's fucking... I'm gonna fucking use this.
That's fucking right.
Smack!
Oh god.
That's fucking right.
I will use the stick if it's the last thing I'll do.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
You can't hit me.
Oh my god, he hit me.
Smack!
Oh, wait.
He hits me here?
What?
Please, let me out.
Please.
Please, this is not fair.
No!
It's not fair.
Why is he so strong?
Why is he...
It's cause he's a billionaire.
Mr. Frog has so much money.
He can do whatever the fuck he wants.
Like, it doesn't matter what he does.
People would still vote for him for president.
Even if he...
If he eats a monkey.
I mean, if he wasn't eating me, I'd vote for him for president too.
Oh my god, bro.
This guy is so fucking strong.
What is your weakness?
Okay.
Damn!
Smack.
Big baby.
Fire!
No!
His weakness is dead.
Like, his fucking moves are actually crazy.
Like, what the fuck is that?
He's just trying to smack me!
In the back!
Okay, that's fine.
That doesn't hit me.
That... I... I swear to fucking god.
Oh!
I'm trying to heal!
Oh my god!
I'm just trying to heal!
Please!
Have mercy!
Have mercy on me!
Oh my god!
This AOE is insane!
This AOE is actually crazy!
No!
There's no way!
There's no way you eat me after that!
There's no fucking way!
This stupid frog!
Oh my god!
This stupid fucking frog!
I will throw!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Please!
Let me off!
Thank you!
I'm 1 HP!
I'm actually 1 HP!
What the fuck was that frog?!
Oh my god!
That has to be the hardest boss I fought so far!
Like, what the fuck was wrong with him?!
But I did it!
I was actually 1 HP.
That was insane!
That's insane.
I literally had no more HP for that fight.
Goddamn, Mr. Frog.
Don't fuck the frog while playing a monkey.
No!
Lali, stop!
Stop!
It's not what I meant.
No!
Oh shit.
Guys, I learned a new move.
It only took me three chapters.
Boom!
Okay, bye.
Goodbye.
Good fucking bye.
Okay, down I'll go.
There must be something down here, right?
Like, why else would I have to go downstairs?
Alright, nice.
Nice, willpower.
There has to be something down here, right?
Why else would there be a downstairs portion?
Like, is he evil?
Guys, he looks evil.
Oh shit!
Oh, you tried to surprise me?
I heard you a mile away, man bat.
Oh, regular bat bat?
Sorry, you're just bat bat.
Wait, there's another...
Where am I?
Where...
I already unlocked a new shrine.
Where am I?
How do I unlock a new shrine?
Where the fuck am I?
There.
Oh my god.
I'm already here, but where is here?
How did I get here?
I think I was not supposed to...
Oh my god.
Where am I?
I'm pretty sure, like...
I was supposed to come down from this direction or something.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was supposed to come down from here.
Because, like, there is a bridge here.
How did I get here?
Guys...
Wow!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Get down from here.
Get down.
That's fucking right.
You didn't surprise me this time.
So predictable.
Alright.
Over you all go.
Oh!
Oh, is he dead?
Where did his body go?
Oh my god.
I killed this man.
Don't worry.
He doesn't know.
Easy.
Wait.
Are you alive still?
No.
Wait.
What?
You're still alive?
Okay.
Alright.
Now he's dead.
Dead for real.
I...
Okay.
So that's where I came from.
Does that mean there's stuff here?
There might be stuff here, actually.
Okay.
Oh, there might be stuff down here.
There's another hole.
Must find the goal.
Oh my god.
Where is the goal?
Where?
There's so many holes.
Which one is the real goal?
The goal.
Alright.
Here?
Are you the goal?
What the fuck?
Is it here?
Is this the goal?
No, what the fuck?
There's still frog people here?
You killed your king!
I killed Mr. Frog!
Are you still here?
Okay, poison?
No, I didn't.
Okay.
Nice.
Every hole is the goal, Doki.
What do you mean?
Nice.
Alright, tree pro.
That might be overkill.
Okay, there's a frog here.
Where am I?
Like at...
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
Why are you just hitting your gun?
Oh, he woke them up!
Through...
Is he a monkey?
Oh no, that's...
What did I kill?
What the fuck did I...
I'm...
Is it a monkey?
You're a monkey?
You do not look like a monkey.
Okay.
Wow!
Okay, that was...
Are you fucking...
Holy fuck!
You know what?
Who can play that game?
Go, monkeys, go!
Do your thing, monkeys!
I got the big guy!
You get all the smaller guys!
Alright, nice.
Nice, they all got the smaller guys.
I got the big ones.
They are confused.
Monkey confused.
We did it, monkeys!
Oh, together now!
The whole neighborhood showed up.
Oh, there's him again!
That's the medicine guy.
That we saved earlier.
Monkeys together strong.
Hello!
Yeah, no shit.
It's the fucking mountains!
Oh!
You need fire?
I got you.
I got you!
Oh no, I don't got you.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to find the shrine.
I'm still trying to find the shrine!
Where the fuck is the shrine?
Coke!
Oh shit, where did you come from?
Oh no!
Here we go.
I know!
Okay, I'm trying to figure...
Oh, there it is.
Wait, that's not fair!
They like guarded the shrine.
Yeah, but...
I didn't expect monsters to be at the shrine.
Usually, they're never at the shrine.
Okay, uh... spells.
Which one is it?
Here you go.
Ring of Fire.
Alright, just for you, my dude.
That's right, you're very special because you get your very own Ring of Fire.
Fire!
Maybe you should have worn pants, old man.
You should have worn some pants, dude.
Like, after the Ring of Fire is over, you still have to go through the...
How did you get up here in the first place?
Yeah, wear some shoes, old man.
Watermel... Does this look like a place for watermelons right now?
He says that he says that he says that he says that.
Is that it?
Oh my god, it's because he's magic!
Yeah.
What if it's a tube or something?
Hey, look at the watermelons over there.
They're already eaten.
So the watermelons can't be eaten?
It's a cube?
There's no cube?
No, there's not a cube.
What is it?
You're running out of time.
What's wrong?
The computer says the computer's weak.
There are no computers in this area.
The only thing that works is to cast a spell.
Sorry, I was blowing my nose.
I guess he would be gone when I set up the immobilize.
Is he gone now?
Oh, he's gone.
But he is gone.
What the fuck?
That's all it took?
He's better now?
Well, I guess he's okay now, I guess.
I guess that's all it took to be okay.
Literally, just a little fire magic.
Alright.
Yes, of course I'm muted.
Only tier 20 memberships can hear the sneeze.
If I let you guys hear it, it won't be fair to the people who pay tier 20.
Say the price?
If you're wondering the price, that means you couldn't afford the tier 20.
The people who...
The people who could afford tier 20 are already...
are already in it.
Folk!
Oh, yeah.
Dang.
Alright.
Let's see.
Kai, welcome to tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
They're like, wait, is this the sneeze in the tomato farm?
Alright, let's see.
Where do I go?
Wait, where did I come from?
Fuck, okay.
I'll figure this out.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
It's always this man.
You know what, bro?
Fuck this.
I can't.
Big baby.
I... Oh my god, he's so tanky!
Jesus!
How is he so tanky?
Do I have to use all my magic on you?
Oh my god, this is like a mini boss fight.
Wait, is this a... Oh, he hits a boss!
I was like... I was like, is he a boss?
Like... Oh, sorry, I just realized he has his own name.
Like... Yeah, I think he...
Whoa, what is he doing?
Okay, I was like, is he gonna just keep growing?
Oh, he did grow!
Over here.
Oh, that's not who I wanted to hit.
I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
Why is he still growing?
Like, what?
That makes sense.
I didn't realize he was an actual boss.
I was like, wait, he has a name.
He has an actual name.
They've never had names before.
Alright.
Look.
Everything eventually has to die.
It was his time.
It was as prophesized in the Wukong books.
Tao, thank you for the super chat.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Yeah, this is how they're supposed to look.
I was like, how the fuck was he so big?
Sorry, I opened with Wraith ult.
Last Apex I played is Apex.
Oh my... That is a long time.
Apex Mobile.
That game doesn't even exist anymore.
But yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What is this?
Is this a watermelon?
No, that's a Jadus.
Yes, Essence.
Alright.
Where do I go?
I guess I go up?
I wonder how many more bosses I have left in general.
I guess I'll go up.
I think I went everywhere down, right?
Like, I don't even know where I am anymore.
I've actually lost track.
I legitimately lost track as to where I am in this game.
I've actually lost track as to where I am in this game.
I just hope that I'm at the right area.
Find a treasure?
Where could the treasure be?
Okay.
Am I heading to the right area for the treasure?
Hello?
How do you hear me?
You're blind!
Not fair!
Sorry.
Bam!
Oh my god, Doki.
That's fucked up.
Beating up a blind person?
I'm going to fucking write a tweet longer about you right now.
Look, it was self-defense.
Being blind doesn't mean I can't hit back.
He is not dead.
If I get hit by a blind person, I will self-defend myself.
Like, it does not exempt you.
You still hit somebody.
Is it down here?
Is this a cliff?
I don't want to jump.
I'm scared.
I'm scared I'm going to get punished for that.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Did I reach it?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's him again.
It's the flying guys.
Oh shit!
What the?
That dodged it?
I can't even tell if I dodged that.
They won't see it coming.
Hahaha.
Exactly.
How would they know?
They're flying.
Alright.
Nice.
I got something.
I don't know what I got.
Yeah, I was like, did I dodge it?
I thought I immobilized, but it shows that I dodged.
So I was like confused.
Oh, it's a perfect dodge using immobilize?
Yeah, planned.
Whoa.
Wolves?
You're silly.
Whoa!
Wolves with knives?
Oh god, they're twins.
For now.
Whoa!
Who gave these wolves knives?
Yeah, I can't fucking do your fancy.
Oh shit.
Maybe you can.
You know what?
Say baby.
That's right.
Now you're not a twin anymore.
Hahaha.
No more twins for me.
For you.
Now your mother is going to have two funerals.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Get the fuck out of here.
This is Wukan land.
Oh, he's praying.
That's sweet.
At least you'll be there with him.
Look, I was just being nice.
I was like taking him.
I was taking him to whoever he was praying to.
There's a corpse?
I don't know.
What the fuck is that?
Evil?
Oh shit.
I have to hit his foot.
Okay.
Free time?
I guess?
Alright.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Wait.
Does he respawn?
Oh my god.
Big baby.
This was...
Remember him?
This was big baby.
Now he's a teenager.
Hahaha.
Remember him?
He's a teenager now, guys.
Jesus Christ.
He's so fucking tanky.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
Haha.
That's fucking right.
You deserve this.
You fucking deserve this.
That's right.
How dare you grow up?
Hahaha.
I thought I ended your bloodline?
How dare you become an adult?
Whoa.
Over-traumatic baby.
Even though he got to grow up mentally, he still hasn't.
Alright.
Nice.
What is he?
Wait.
What was he?
Hahaha.
Wait.
What was he?
Oh no, I can't... I don't know.
Oh no, I lost track.
Is this one?
Dark face?
Oh, it has to be him.
That's fucking right.
Down with all babies.
What have they done for us anyway?
Like...
Babies?
If you guys didn't know, human babies are known as one of the worst babies in the animal kingdom.
They're like every other baby animal is like...
When a deer is born, they can...
They can walk.
They can like, you know...
They can poop without assistance.
They...
They can technically talk if you think about it.
Like in their language, in their baby language.
Like...
What can fucking human babies do?
Human babies can't even walk.
They can't even walk.
They can't do taxes.
Yeah.
Human babies can't even do their own taxes.
Like, what's the point?
Oh, shit.
I was not... I was fucking around.
They can't even...
Exactly!
Human babies can't even fucking cough properly.
We have to smack them in the butt so they can cough.
So they can burp.
They can burp.
All I'm saying is that I think human babies are the most worthless babies out of all the babies in the world.
Like, literally any other baby is better than a human baby.
The only baby that's worse than a human baby is a kangaroo baby.
Like, kangaroo moms literally don't care.
They...
How do you guys know this?
But kangaroo moms really...
Like, the moment the baby is like something, it just comes out.
It's like barely a thing.
They're just like, get in the pouch.
You live there now.
Oh, shit.
Unlucky.
Can you get closer to me while I use this stick?
And don't throw the thing.
Oh, no.
He's not gonna...
He knows.
You don't fuck this.
I can't be bothered to deal with your bullshit.
I can't be bothered.
You're gonna...
I'm just gonna turn into a big tiger boy.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need you guys...
Baby turtles?
They can fuck...
I don't know yet.
Baby turtles can at least like walk.
Human babies can't even crawl.
Chat.
Okay.
We gotta get rid of him apparently.
They won't let me...
They won't let me use the shrine until I get rid of this guy.
Which is fucked.
No, they can't.
It takes them like certain amount of months to crawl.
They can't even do that.
Alright.
Okay, baby turtles?
Baby turtles?
It's not their fault that like everybody wants to fucking eat a baby turtle.
Like...
Hey, it's not...
It's not their fault.
Like everybody in the beach...
Okay, I'll show you guys what a baby kangaroo looks like.
It's actually pretty fucked.
Um...
When they are born, they look like...
Like they literally...
Let me look at...
Actually, it's pretty disgusting.
Okay.
I need to warn you guys.
I need to know.
This is literally...
This is how the kangaroo poops the baby out.
It's so fucked.
This is...
Bro, it doesn't have any...
It's like a jelly.
It's like...
Alright, get in my pouch now.
And it lives in the pouch.
That's literally...
That's literally what it looks like.
Yeah, they literally...
Poop the baby out when it's like...
A fetus.
And then...
And then they're like...
Crawl into the pouch now.
That's like the only thing...
That's worse than a human baby.
It's literally a...
Kangaroo baby.
A kangaroo baby is like a fetus.
So, wait.
Um...
Okay, kangaroo...
Baby kangaroo...
Uh, there's like a...
Diagram.
I hate how...
How they do that.
It's so fucking weird.
I remember when I...
When I like saw it...
I was like, what the fuck?
How the fuck is it...
How the fuck did they decide...
To do that?
You're right!
Even as a...
No, you're fucking right.
Nevermind.
You're right.
Human babies are like...
We fucked up.
You said we're like...
Oh Doki, you're spoiling...
Your dog.
We have spoiled babies so fucking hard.
That like...
That even...
A fetus.
A kangaroo fetus...
Can crawl.
Like it's literally...
Crawling...
To the pouch.
Please...
Please, we don't want to see it.
Okay, fine.
Fine!
No education...
For you, I guess.
Apparently...
Oh wait, I can brew something else.
What's this?
Uh...
36% And a moderate amount...
Oh, wait!
A mana!
Wait, that's good.
I might as well get the mana one too.
Okay, um...
Laurel turtle breath.
Okay.
Laurel...
What is breath again?
Which one's breath?
Uh...
Oh, I'll get the breath and the laurel beads then.
Breath and laurel beads.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, apparently I missed something.
Where do I have to go?
Guys, I missed something.
I missed a boss.
Where do I have to go?
Where do I have to go, guys?
Let's see...
Uh... Oh wait, I only selected one of the soaks?
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh, I did!
Okay, was it breath, right?
Yeah, breath.
Because the other ones fucking suck.
Uh...
First chapter of the red...
Wait, no, we already got...
We already beat red dragon though.
Forest...
Uh, we already did red dragon.
What am I missing?
Someone said that I'm missing, like...
Um, something in this area.
I'm missing a boss in this area.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Human babies are hyper-specialized to favor the growth of the most important organ, the brain.
A realtor's capacity was sacrificed for it.
Babies can still instinctually swim, though.
Oh yeah, I've seen videos of people just fucking throwing their babies in the water, just for...
Like, just...
Like, they just...
They're supposed to be like, see?
We're gonna teach our baby how to fucking swim.
Like, that's so fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
That's crazy that the brain is, like, prioritized when, like, I'm, like, an example of a failure of that.
I might as well walk early instead.
Like, alright.
Where do we go?
Which way?
We go up?
Did I go up before?
I can't tell.
Oh, he's a corpse!
Why are you a woman?
Oh, it's the fox!
I was like, I'm pretty sure that's a guy!
Wait, is that the woman from chapter 2?
Oh, it's the!
It's the... it's the guy from the chapter two.
It's the same one!
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, you want me to kill him?
Wow!
I'm her!
I'm woman!
Alright.
I guess it's time to avenge her broken heart, I guess.
Alright, let's go.
I don't know where I'm going, but okay.
Where do I go?
I'm her now.
Real woman Doki Bee?
Real female?
Wait, can you smack me?
Okay, apparently they can't.
I need to figure this out.
Whoops,
I guess... I guess you're not gonna... we're not gonna avenge you.
Okay, I guess.
Alright, let's... let's fix that.
Alright, let's see.
What's that spell?
Wait, where is it?
Where did it... where is it?
Oh, I can transform... Oh, I can transform anytime!
Okay.
Oh, is it this one?
Oh...
Okay, there you go.
Alright, we're fine.
Everything is fine now.
Alright.
Do we just go up?
Where's the shrine?
Is this just up?
I'm just gonna go up.
I have no idea where this shrine is.
What the fuck?!
What's the point of being a...
What's the point of being a woman?
What's the point of being a woman if it can just hit me?
Like...
Like, I might just be a regular monkey at this point.
Like, this is not fair!
Why can't I use this in my current state?
Oh my god, I'm just gonna go to the temple.
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I might as well just be a regular monkey.
Like, what's the point?
Poke!
Why can he, she just... Why can people just hit me like that?
Alright, nice.
Okay, here we go.
Like, I assume...
I assume that, like, you know, when you're...
You're Fox Lady, you don't get hit.
But you can still get hit, so what's the point?
Okay.
Gotta get this.
Wait, where do I go after that?
Guys, I don't think I was supposed to do that.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't think I was...
Where am I?
Where the fuck did I fall?
Wait.
Oh, this is the frog!
Okay!
I got way back to the frog!
Okay.
Alright, guys.
I actually went back to the frog, guys.
Whoops.
I just wanted to kill that one guy again, I guess.
I'm just farming money at this point.
I'll always be lost.
I'll never find my way.
I'll never...
Bum, bum, bum.
Ba-da-dum.
Bum, ba-da-dum.
Da-da-na-na-num.
Alright, where do I go?
Where the fuck?
I'm just gonna kill this one guy.
Whew!
Okay, get out.
Oh, hey, I got gold.
This is the path, though, isn't it?
Don't even know anymore.
I don't even know anymore.
Oh, no!
There's nothing here.
Okay, this was not it.
Somebody said go up!
I just listened!
Is it this?
Oh my god, where the fuck is this pathway you guys all speak of?
Is this the path?
There's so many frozen dudes, guys.
You gotta be very specific on which frozen dude is the right dude.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Ow!
My god!
Who gave you that big-ass sword?
My big-ass sword now.
Not big enough, clearly.
Am I over- Is Wukong overcompensating?
Alright.
Is it this way?
Am I going the right way?
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Fuck!
Okay.
That's awkward.
No, I was here before.
This chest was open.
Wait.
I was here before.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
I've clearly been here before!
Where is this place?!
They all look- They all look the same!
I can't remember!
It all looks the same!
Okay, I'm going the right way.
Alright, that's all that matters.
I'll hydrate real fast.
Previously on Lost.
Is this it?
Do I go this way?
Oh, it's you guys again!
Wait, you're alive?!
I thought I killed you guys!
It's okay.
I can make him a single child again.
As your mom intended.
Your mom hired me because she can't take care of both of you.
Like, that's too many miles to feed.
Your mom hired me to make sure there will be no more children.
Alright, they grow back.
Okay, I assume I have to go this way then.
Uh, I guess I go this way?
Follow the path?
Alright, nice.
Down we go!
Just want to make sure that these guys don't bother me.
What?!
Okay, it's fine.
We can still- We can still do this.
Bam!
Alright.
Just gonna hydrate.
There has to be like an incense area nearby.
Like, I- There's no way I have to go in there with like 0 HP.
Oh shit, no.
Oh no.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Absorb.
Alright.
Oh, there it is!
Nice.
Oh wait, this is the- Oh!
I was here before.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
This should be it, right?
Like...
Alright.
And then we go...
Oh hey, it's the eagle!
Oh my god, I fucking hate you.
I'm not kidding.
Hehehe.
I actually fucked you.
Like...
You know what?
I'm fucking bringing the big baby time.
You don't deserve anything.
You don't deserve anything in life.
How dare you fly!
I fucking- I could rip the wings off your body.
That's not psychopathic at all!
There we go.
Alright.
Uh-oh.
It's not like we should do this.
Alright, he's gonna come over here.
Okay, I guess not.
I wasted my entire thing.
I decided to throw a snowball for once.
Alright.
Oh, that should be it!
It's red!
Oh, wait, what?
All I'm saying is that...
is that some birds just do not deserve to fly, and that's one of the birds.
Alright.
Okay.
That should be him, right?
Alright, now I can be Wolfman.
Where is my inventory?
Fox Moon!
There I go.
How dare you follow your dreams, boy?
How fucking dare you?
Oh, what's that?
Ugh.
I hate that sound.
It's like so fleshy.
Hello, I'm here.
Oh, that's why.
It's literally blood.
Hello.
Oh!
Okay.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm literally a fox.
I...
Okay.
Alright, today I learned that, like, it didn't...
I couldn't do anything about it.
I'm literally a fucking fox.
Poke!
Woo!
Got your dick!
Alright.
Fire!
Ow!
Okay.
That...
Okay, bro.
Chill out.
Chill...
Actually...
Chill out, bro.
Oh, yeah.
He's gonna whack you in the shins, I guess.
I like how the majority of these...
like, giant-ass bosses, I'm just whacking their shins.
Like...
He's just...
Just some fucking ant beating up his feet.
Alright.
What's he doing?
Oh, shit!
Like, what is he gonna do?
Fucking kick me?
Like, ow!
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm actually gonna do it.
Like...
I don't know what I think actually happened.
Okay.
Yes.
He was...
That was absolutely the strat.
That's getting you chow received.
How the fuck was I supposed to know he could just kick me?
Anyway, he's dead.
That was easy.
What are you gonna do?
Shoot me?
I'm gonna...
Man holding a gun.
What are you gonna do?
Shoot me?
Nice.
We got the other chief.
I think we were missing one more chief, right?
Oh, jing san...
That's what he looks like?!
That...
I did not see a head.
Like, where was your head?
That was not what it looked like.
A tiny monkey was smacking your shins when you kick it.
Hahaha!
Oh, that was the plank.
Yeah!
Yeah, I was like, bro, my lore thing is all fucking messed up.
It's so behind schedule.
That was before the surgery.
I was like, that cannot be what it looked like.
There's no way.
Where the fuck is the YoGuyChief, right?
Wait, wasn't it a YoGuyChief?
Where was he?
Or was he a king?
Oh, there's the red dragon.
That was not... Okay, yeah, that was what he looks like.
It was a captain?
The fuck?
Captain...
Kalpa White.
Okay, we're gonna find him.
He has to be a king, right?
There... No, that's Y's voice.
Hey, where is he?
Does he not exist?
Hey, there's the dog.
Look for legs.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, there he goes.
Yeah, that's what he looked like.
Yeah, that's how he looked.
Yeah, that's sort of how he looked like, I guess.
All right, is it time for a wolf lady?
Wolfman?
Is it time for you to show up?
Wolfman.
Wolf lady is here.
She's here now.
Hello.
I'm here to...
avenge...
I'm here to avenge my death.
I guess not.
Okay, we gotta...
Just gotta get this first.
I want to rest up.
All right, wolf lady time.
Wolf lady.
All right, here I am.
Hello, sir.
I'm here to avenge...
Wolf lady.
Is that you?
Goodbye.
Where the fuck do you live?
Is that you?
Where does he live?
Box lady confused.
Oh, he's in the side room?
Wait, keep going?
Okay, upstairs and go left.
Okay.
Goodbye, guys.
It's so nice that like they're not attacking me now that I'm...
I'm just a little fox lady.
He's further ahead?
Yeah?
All right, goodbye.
Fox lady confused.
Fox lady just want to avenge.
Just wants revenge.
That's not you.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
No, please.
Please, fox lady doesn't know what to do.
No!
How did you know?
Holy shit!
Wait, you're just a person.
What the fuck?
You're literally just a man.
Like holy shit.
Bro, he's just a...
Bro, I beat up so many yaguas.
You're just a fucking man.
He's blind.
He's still a man.
What the fuck?
Overseeing monk.
Oh.
He's not even blind.
He just chose to cover his eyes.
All right.
Let's see.
Here we go.
Doesn't know.
Stupid.
I don't know what to do.
What the fuck?
No.
Jesus Christ.
Where the...
What the fuck?
How did he know?
Like that's fucking crazy.
He was ready to swing.
How did he know though?
Okay, back to fox lady.
What do you mean I cannot use it?
Alright, where is it?
Where is he?
Where is the guy?
Am I still in combat?
Is he still trying to... oh, you're blind!
Stop!
Guys, you're blind!
It's embarrassing for you.
You should stop that.
You should really stop that, man.
What the fuck?
That's not even you!
Oh god, oh no.
Oh, this is a different guy!
That's electrocuting me!
He's not even part of the fight!
The other guy's not even blind!
It's not fair!
Oh my god, bro.
I just... I just...
Please, just let me kill this blind man.
Please.
It's self-defense, man.
Come on.
He doesn't care about self-defense, clearly.
Oh!
That's who you were!
Hey, your buddy's getting beat up right now.
You don't care?
Okay, that's good.
Thank god.
It's not fair!
He has a vision!
Okay, where do I go?
Straight or left, guys?
Straight up?
Okay, first we're gonna take the fox lady over first.
I'm gonna take the fox lady over to, like, the dead guy.
I mean, that's not the end of the story anyway, right?
Wait.
Is he the... Is the fox lady the end of the story?
Is that the end of the story?
Wait, is it?
Oh, no?
Okay, I'm just gonna go then.
Other way for the fox lady?
Oh.
The fuck is this way?
Okay, it's just a side quest, so it doesn't matter.
Okay, this way.
Here?
Is it up here?
Then left sta- This one?
Or this one?
Oh, up there?
Okay.
All right.
All right, here we go.
They don't know.
Is it you?
Are you a bad guy?
No - No,
I'm not a bad guy.
This is...
in that...
Well, they bear it, right?
Connect me to Spidey.
I'll go bye-bye.
Trans buckle.
Justin - Mazel.
Why would she find peace?
You literally killed her!
That's right.
I wasn't your wife.
I was a monkey instead.
JK, I was a monkey man.
What do you mean?
Everything I do is for revenge.
Like...
What the fuck?
How do you move so fast?
You're old.
Wait, that's not fair.
Where did those reflexes come from?
You couldn't use those reflexes to save your fucking dead son in that dream?
That's fucking right.
I said it.
Jesus Christ, your reflexes.
What's he doing?
That's just paper.
That's not going to hurt me.
I don't think the paper is going to hurt me, guys.
I think the paper is going to hurt me, guys.
Oh my god.
Guys, that paper looks mighty dangerous right about now.
I thought it was just paper.
I guess not.
Bam!
Oh, what?
That was my co- That was my strongest- Oh shit!
What?
It went by so fast.
I was so close.
His rejectiles were so fast.
I couldn't dodge it.
How did I die in a pa- Oh no, I have to do this all over again.
I don't remember how I got there.
I don't even know.
Oh shit, okay.
Alright, we're going to figure- Oh no.
Okay, we're going to figure it out.
We're going to figure it out.
We can do this, I believe.
I believe.
Oh yeah!
He- Wait, that makes sense.
He became a wizard.
You're right.
He never made after that.
He never got with the fox wife.
So he became a wizard.
So he became a monk.
He never married again.
It's so true.
It's true.
I was like, how the fuck did you turn into this guy?
You were like a fucking- Like a- Like some emperor's guard or some shit.
Okay, I don't really remember the pathways.
I'm just swinging it.
Oh, please don't hurt me.
No, please don't hurt me.
Don't hurt me.
Oh, he doesn't know- He- Oh no, I got lost!
Oh!
Oh,
my waist didn't- Okay, I fell off.
Okay, I fell off.
I fell down.
I accidentally fell down, guys.
Okay.
That's fine.
So happens.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Then we beat up the other magician.
I fell off, guys.
I fell off.
I miss-o-doki.
Peek-doki.
Nuff.
Wash-doki.
Okay, it was this, and then it was up here.
I remember.
I'll get rid of him just in case.
Like, fuck this one guy in particular.
I don't like how he looks.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, not- I forgot.
I didn't realize I ran past these wizards before.
Alright, now I know.
I need to turn.
Nice, alright.
Alright, we're going in already.
Like, a bit HP lost, but that's fine.
I guess.
That's fine.
Alright.
Big baby!
That's fucking right.
And then Wolfman!
Wolf.
Wolf!
That's fucking right.
No paper for you.
Oh shit.
Oh no, he's gonna use the power of paper again.
Okay.
I can do the same.
The power of hair!
That's fucking right!
Ow!
The power of hair!
That's right!
If you can use paper, I shall use hair!
Oh my god.
Like, I can't even hit you.
Like...
What the fuck!
Jesus!
Poke!
What?!
Wait a minute, I can't just poke you!
Alright.
I guess I run.
Paper coming.
No, he's a level 100 wizard!
He's the strongest wizard of them all!
Holy fuck!
Jesus.
Oh my god, he is a strong wizard.
This is what happens when he has no bitches.
Oh my god, bro.
What the fuck, bro!
Get a bitch!
Come on!
No bitches for this poor old man!
Oh...
Oh no!
That's five!
No, that's not five!
Oh my god!
I did it!
Oh...
You can be one.
I can do it.
Oh well.
I'll try it.
Yeah, at least you get to die a wizard.
As long as she doesn't...
I can do it!
I can do it too!
Oh, no.
oh, no.
He's maiden-less.
Yoink!
You're my soul now!
Oh my god!
Should've banged the fox lady!
Life would've been happier for you!
Not gonna lie!
I feel like life would've been happier for you if you banged the fox lady.
Talk to the fox lady again?
I am the fox lady.
Why would I need to talk to myself?
Is there like an incense near me, guys?
Or do I suffer?
Do I suffer?
Oh, I have instant TP.
Okay.
Thank god.
I guess I suffer by going back to the temple again.
Oh, I have to be not fox lady to use it.
Alright.
Alright, confirm.
Oh, fuck you, Tommy.
The entire palace area is a maze where I ran around for two hours.
Oh god.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Where is the dead fox lady?
Is it here?
Is it Longevity Road?
Where is it called?
Is it the Forest of Felicity?
Okay, Forest of Felicity.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Hello.
I did it.
Woah,
you're gonna kill his fucking children.
I mean, like, he wasn't gonna take the 50-50, like...
Hey!
Like, yeah, he gets to...
bang hot fox lady.
But, like, there was a chance.
It was just a...
That was a very real dream.
That was...
Alright.
50-50.
The man just did that weak.
He was weak!
He could...
Man, jeez.
I...
Wait, how do I read the story?
Did it show up?
Losing 50-50.
Is it the characters?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
A fox subsided with Cephas' heart.
It ceased to pass the horizon, journeying far.
Yet fate unknown, her end draws near before it sees the stars.
Commune one above and become a fa- Oh, it's immortal!
You can't even kill her!
She's immortal!
Oh, but it's very hard to become immortal.
You have to excel arts and philosophy to be immortal?
God, let me just be immortal then.
Once you transform, you can take the form of a beautiful woman or a handsome man.
And go to human towns to study and learn.
But remember this.
Lady of Mount Tai oversees all foxes and despises those who seduce and consume humans.
You must know that absorbing human essence is the quickest way for a Yaoguai to become powerful.
And if you wish to become a fox immortal, this path is forbidden.
You must set off a much more perilous and injurious path.
Alright.
Oh!
She might not have ate him.
Because it was against the fox law.
It was against fox law.
So...
I mean, she could have fallen into the temptation.
You don't know that.
She could...
She might not...
Yeah, but she might not have ate him.
She...
I mean, living near humans...
Like, living near humans all the time...
Like, it only takes one hit.
It only...
What if she accidentally, like, slurped up some blood?
You know?
She could have, like...
She could have accidentally slurped up the blood and then transformed.
Because she's like, Wait, that's actually pretty good.
Like,
what if...
Like, that could have happened.
Yeah.
Stealing is against the law.
But they still...
But people still do it.
All it takes is one nipple.
That's all it takes.
One nipple and it's over.
It's over for her.
That was literally a 50-50.
Why are you so pessimistic?
50-50 are not good odds.
That's what I'm saying.
It's not that...
I'm just saying, 50-50 is, like, not the best odds you can have.
And we're not!
Gotcha!
Yeah, the RAM was 50-50 and look what...
Guys, it's because ever since the RAM, I could never trust any 50-50s ever again.
Ever since the RAM issue.
The RAM was 50-50 and look what happened to me.
I went to the PC store like three fucking times because of the RAM.
Wait, I don't get the paintbrush?
I lose the paintbrush forever?
That's fucked!
Why can't I keep you, fox lady?
I could have treated you right.
Oh, it's an equip.
Oh, okay, nice.
I want to be fox lady.
Oh, it turned into a curiosity item?
Alright.
Jesus!
Oh my god!
You're not fucking killing me!
I will heal, bitch!
Jesus Christ!
I miss being fox lady.
But fox lady let me walk past everything.
I don't want to fight them.
They're so annoying.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
How do I become fox lady?
Where is it?
Is this?
No.
It increases critical hit chance.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, no.
No.
Hit on empty void.
Land enough success hits to avoid the next fatal blow.
Oh, wait, it's this.
Modern increase.
Wait, that's good!
Wait, what's this?
When slightly reduced cooldown of spells.
Ah, fuck!
Okay.
The increases duration trans...
I'll just equip that for the...
Um...
That's not fair!
I can't...
Oh my god, you're right.
I should have went to...
Guys, now I know why you guys were like, go to the...
Go to the horse now!
Because...
Because now I have to do this without fox lady.
Alright, where's the horse?
I'm not gonna fight the tiger!
I'm not gonna get...
I'm gonna upgrade my weapon first before I fight the tiger.
Alright, where's the horse?
Is it the...
Same place?
Okay.
Trans Okay, that's fine.
He can't get me?
He's fucking blind.
Okay...
Wait, the horse wasn't there?
What do you mean the horse wasn't there?
What do you mean?
There's different horses?
Where would the horse be?
I have to go back to chapter... oh my god.
Go back to chapter one.
Who the fuck is he?
Now there's a horse.
Who are you?
Let me finish chapter three you fucking horse!
Okay, what do we do?
What do we do?
Where is he?
Where is he guys?
Where the fuck is he?
Give it to me.
Black Hill Shrine.
Where the fuck is Black Hill Shrine?
One of the meditation?
Somewhere in Bamboo Grove.
Okay.
Alright, where the fuck is...
What the fuck is somewhere in Bamboo Grove?
That is not enough information.
Alright,
we can do this.
I am strong.
To the left.
I feel like this game is like...
The game realizes you're like...
You're actually lost.
It just gives you the yellow fly thing.
Is he here?
Is he in here?
Horseman, where are you?
Is he here?
To the left.
Horseman.
Oh hey, I didn't get this chest.
Okay.
Loot.
Loot I didn't get.
Alright.
At least I got loot.
Okay, the opposite way.
Abago.
Okay.
This way.
And then down.
Abago.
And then to the left.
To the left.
Here.
Is this it?
Oh, are you Horseman?
Whoa!
Did I steal your stuff?
Oh no.
Okay.
Alright.
That's furry bait right there.
Bro,
why are you so jacked?
Bro, he has veins on his fucking foot.
Bro, did you see those veins on his fucking hooves?
Geez.
Oh, is that your weapon?
Are you carrying a whip?
Oh, I already killed him.
Already killed that guy.
Oh, I already killed that guy.
The dragoons really wanted to see you, and now I know why.
Alright, goodbye.
Alright.
The dragoons really wanted me to meet you, and now I know why.
Now I know why.
I get it too!
Oh wait, can I meditate?
Oh wait, I was supposed to meditate there?
Was there a meditation there?
I didn't even realize.
Whoopskiss, I gotta go back again.
I'm mad.
Thank you for the secret chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Where the fuck is the meditation spot?
Oh, there it is.
Whoa, wolf box!
Whoa!
That was a jacked horse.
I'm glad he was wearing...
I'm glad he was wearing pants.
I'm glad he's one of the animals that actually wore clothes.
Alright.
Nice.
I didn't want to meditate while he was watching me.
I felt weird.
I know some of you freaks would have liked that.
Okay, chapter two.
Alright.
Chapter two time!
Where is it?
Where is it in the first...
Is it village entrance or...
Where was it?
Village entrance?
Okay.
Alright.
Off we go to the village entrance.
Where was the mini boss?
Okay, that was the frog guy, right?
Near the frogs?
Here?
Or like...
Oh, the earth dog!
Oh, that village... that boss!
The fucking dog that looked like a rat.
That guy.
Okay, I remember him.
Alright.
The fucking dog-rat thing.
It should be here.
Alright, over here.
I've trained.
There we go.
You should be like super weak.
Right now.
Like you should be dead dead.
Alright, horse man.
What the fuck were you talking to?
My dragoons.
They really want to see you again.
Oh, so you're tied up.
How did they tie you up?
Look at you!
He is.
Bro!
You look so vulnerable right now.
He is really vulnerable.
Yeah.
Please stop.
These rats are no match for me.
Then how the fuck did you get tied up?
Even though you are a beast, you can't get away with it.
I wonder what he said in English.
That's a good question.
Wait, how are you going to get out?
Are you going to... No, I can't talk to him no more.
I want to know what he said in English.
I want to know it.
What the fuck?
How is he like stuck?
Oh, use fire?
Okay, I'll be back.
Do I untie him?
Or does he untie himself?
He's acting helpless to lower the guard.
He's like, don't worry, I can take it.
Then how did you get caught?
How the fuck did you get caught?
Okay.
Apparently, I can talk to him again.
Okay, let's see.
I'll check.
I'll double check him.
Like, that rope shouldn't be able to hold you down.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Alright.
The dragoons need to know.
What do you sound like in English?
It's silent.
How odd.
Who would swear fealty to such a thing?
You know what he reminds me of?
You know what his voice reminds me of?
Fifty Shades of Grey.
These rats are no match for me.
The guy from Fifty Shades of Grey.
He literally sort of sounds like him.
No!
This place is a jumble of rats and cats.
Stop!
You've ruined him!
Switch it back!
No!
Why did you have to ruin the horse?
I knew what he sounds like because I saw the trailer.
I didn't watch the movie because, like, I'm not into that.
Like...
Um...
The funniest shit I know about the movie is that the two actors hated each other so much.
They literally did the movie for a paycheck.
They did not like each other.
Because it was a meme!
That movie was a fucking meme!
It was literally...
The whole Fifty Shades of...
Nay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The whole...
The whole fucking premise was...
That fucking...
Move...
This book was based off of a Twilight fanfiction.
Okay.
We gotta go this way.
That's another reason why you would watch that movie.
Yeah!
It was literally...
She literally wrote that on, like, I don't know, Wattpad or some shit.
She, like, uploaded on, like, Wattpad or either fanfiction.net.
I don't fucking remember.
It was like a...
It was...
It was an Edward Bella Twilight fanfiction.
And then, like, she made it into a book.
Like...
And then she changed the names.
And then made it into a fucking book.
The worst part?
It was a mid...
Oh, how do you know that, D-Dragon?
How the fuck do you know it was a mid...
Fanfiction.
I didn't even read the fanfiction.
So how do you know?
Let's see.
Do we go up?
Oh no, it's the blind man.
It's the blind man.
Whoa.
Can't catch me.
We're too blind for that.
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Now where do I go?
Now where's the horseman?
Horseman!
Oh, left side.
Okay.
Left side.
That's it?
Is it here?
Where's horseman?
Where the fuck is horseman?
Other way?
Is my left not your left?
Is it this left?
No, it's the other side left.
Is my left this left?
Is this the left?
Wait, what?
He's in the house?
What house?
Is that him?
Wait, there he is!
I see you!
Hey there, big boy.
I'm your friend!
No more?
What the fuck are those thoughts?
Because he's not wearing underneath that.
Nothing underneath that, guys.
I just realized he's not wearing anything, guys.
He's not wearing anything.
Oh, he really was, huh?
Okay,
sure.
We can be best friends forever.
Maybe even more than that.
Okay, where do I go now?
Starts with friendship first.
Wait, is there a meditation here?
Oh, shit.
There's a gift here.
Did anyone tell you you're nuts?
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we're in, guys.
We're in.
Guys, we're fucking in, guys.
Where do I go?
Oh, I guess I'll do the chest.
I'll open this chest.
Yay, chest!
I don't know where to go.
I'm, like, forever lost.
Oh, there's a meditation spot here.
Is that a meditation spot or is that loot?
Oh, it's loot.
God damn it!
Come on, guys!
Let me have this loot!
It's literally just sitting there!
You guys weren't even gonna do anything with it!
Come on, you know that!
You guys weren't gonna do anything anyway!
I swear to fucking God.
Please, let me use this once.
Oh, my God!
Are the twins gonna kill me?
Jesus Christ!
This is it.
No more...
No more nice monkeys.
Multiple monkey time.
That's fucking right.
You go.
Go do your thing.
You do your thing and then I'm gonna fucking...
I'm gonna kill this guy in particular.
No, no, I didn't die to mobs.
It has not happened, guys.
It has not happened!
I'm just trying to kill this one fucking guy!
There we go.
Alright, there we go.
I used all that just for this fucking mob.
Oh!
Maximum stamina.
It was worth it.
Nice.
It was worth it too.
Wait, are you a mini-boss?
Who the fuck are you?
What the fuck?
Who are you?
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Sorry, I did not mean...
That's not what I wanted to do.
That was actually an accident.
Who are you?
I've never seen you before.
There's so many legs.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I just wanted to do that and then...
I might not be as strong because you're also fire, but that's okay.
I've never seen him before.
Who the fuck is this guy?
Whoa!
That's fine.
Easy.
Oh, I got arm guards!
Let's fucking go.
Might be like a mini-boss or some shit.
Damn.
Oh, what the fuck?
You have feces on your knees?
What the fuck are you?
She got the drops at the first try like it's hard?
Okay,
I'm gonna kill this guy.
All right.
Get out.
I don't even...
He's got the gamer knees.
Bro, he's fucking gaming right now.
Oh, no.
No, no!
There we go.
Yes.
What was he guarding?
Wait, that wasn't even anything.
He was guarding nothing!
What?
All right.
He was actually guarding nothing.
So I can just leave.
Melon quest time.
Did I get everything here?
Is there any extra loot?
Dude, what the fuck are you... God damn it, leave me alone.
I'm best friends with a horse, leave me alone.
Am I missing anything?
I got everything?
Is there any loot that I'm missing?
I'm not missing anything, right?
There's a transformation?
Where?
Where is it?
Go to the main boss?
I missed a pet?
Okay.
Who said that?
Oh, temple entrance?
Okay.
I'm just gonna head here first.
Did I miss anything at the...
Up there?
Did I miss anything up there?
Guys?
No, right?
I'm gonna double check, actually.
Yeah?
Okay, I'm gonna go back in.
That's fucking right.
I'm coming back in to beat you up.
No wizards allowed.
That's fucking right.
No wizards allowed up here.
This is a wizard free zone.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna make sure I didn't miss anything here.
No, there's nothing.
It's just paper.
There's nothing here.
You guys lied!
It's just paper!
Look up?
Why would I need to look up?
Free paper.
Doki, you don't understand.
It's free paper.
That's some good-ass paper, though.
Okay.
Alright, I think... Wait, what?
Okay, here we go.
He's nobody important.
$5,000 paper.
Wow!
What the fuck?
What are you doing fucking meditating out here?
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
Yeah, I already did the fox.
I already did the fox quest.
Alright, is that everything?
Nothing left, right?
I'm free from the temple.
Right?
Am I free?
Did I grab everything I needed to grab?
The last captain's behind me?
What, that guy?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, this guy.
Oh, down.
There's another monk spirit with a spade?
Alright, out I'll go.
That's too much.
East is right.
Wrong way.
I missed the fox lady.
There's so many things to do.
Is it this side?
This way?
This temple is huge.
Holy...
Holy shit.
Oh hey, there's the...
He has a...
He's blue!
Alright.
You're glowing!
That means you're a summon!
Right?
No, he's just like that.
Nevermind.
I don't think he's special.
He's just...
He's just like that.
He's just a regular guy.
JK.
I thought I saw glowing.
I gaslit in myself.
One day we'll see what chapter 3's ending looks like.
One...
I wanna figure it out one day.
We're here forever.
We're just stuck in chapter 3.
We never leave.
We're stuck in the mountains.
Okay.
Okay, I'll leave these guys.
They can just chill down there.
Like...
They do not need to deal with me.
Oh, hey!
Turtle God!
Open.
It's so nice of them to just let me take that for free.
I literally just walked over and be like...
Yoink!
Mine now, I guess.
Just let me walk up and just...
Take it, I guess.
I guess they didn't care as much as I thought they will.
Does this guy have any loot for me?
Just wanna make sure.
Turn the loot back here.
Are you guarding anything?
No.
Okay, you're just there.
Alright, I'll leave you be.
Bye.
Okay, let's just go that way.
Alright, here we go.
Assist...
Sayak, thank you for the 20 gift of ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Whoa!
Why are you guarding?
Monk from the sea?
Oh, shit!
Wait, you're different from the other tentacle monks.
I thought you were like the regular tentacle monks.
The fuck?
Wait, he can do that?
What the fuck?
What the fu- Okay!
He can do a lot apparently.
Oh, god.
Okay.
Go, Wukong!
Go!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine, my gang.
My gang is coming over.
That's fucking right.
Okay, my gang's frozen.
Okay.
They're already frozen, but that's okay.
They're gonna do something!
I believe in them!
All right.
They're gonna do something!
I believe in them!
That's fine.
We're there.
Oh, no.
No, this is not what I wanted.
Okay.
Yay!
Give us nothing!
No!
Oh, I forgot!
This is a lot of snow!
Oh!
Give me a...
You fucking...
Find me here!
Please!
Find me outside of the snow!
That's all I ask!
Stop standing in the snow, you fucker!
Oh, my god.
And I'll walk back.
And then...
You have to not touch snow one day!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
That's all I wanted.
That's...
That is not what I wanted, though.
That...
Okay.
I'll just do this.
Yes!
I'll just...
He just slammed down and I just died!
Oh, my god.
How the fuck...
I don't even remember how to get those this way.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
How did he do that?
How the fuck was that?
How was he able to do that?
That should have been illegal.
That was a legal move right there.
Where was the referee?
Where the fuck was the referee?
That was an illegal move right there.
I need the ref right now to don't check the vons!
Bro, I don't even know if I'm even close to the end of chapter three.
I feel like I'm...
I feel like I'm only at 50% of chapter three right now.
I'm gonna ref this with the whore.
Holy shit.
This guy is crazy.
This guy is insane.
I think the worst part is just the fucking snow.
That's actually...
Did I miss?
Did I...
No way!
Oh, my god.
There's no way.
I can't believe I missed big baby!
How?
How did I miss big baby?
He's literally all I have!
Oh, my god.
Bro, this is...
Bro!
There is he!
Oh, my god.
I feel like they used so much magic!
Okay, just walk to...
No, I swear they got it.
Yeah, bro.
I swear they fucking got it.
Where the fuck is the non-snow?
Oh!
Okay.
There we go.
No, I will never need to resist ice.
No.
Okay.
In his last words.
No!
I will!
You can't make me!
No!
No, no, no, no.
Please.
Where are the non-snow?
Where's the non-snow?
You factual fucker.
Oh, my god.
Come on.
Okay.
We're not okay, though.
We are not okay.
We're absolutely not okay.
I got stuck!
We were so close!
Oh my god, we were so close!
It's okay.
This is it.
I've downloaded his entire moveset.
It's over.
I've downloaded his entire moveset in my head.
I figured it out.
I figured it out now.
It's so over for this fucking man.
No.
I don't need snow resistance.
Snow needs to resist me!
Alright, up I go.
This is it.
I'm beginning to believe.
There's no way.
What can he do?
Slap me?
I'll see about that.
I'm ready.
Duck!
Alright.
Boom!
That's right.
Snow resist this bitch.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Can't do shit no more!
That's right!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go!
Okay.
We're okay.
That's right, get closer.
Get closer.
Yeah, you can't do anything now, huh?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
You can't do anything now.
You're just gonna throw snowballs.
Cause you know you can't do jack shit.
Get closer, bitch.
Come on.
Get over here.
Okay.
You fucker.
Alright, I see how it is.
I fucking see how it is.
I fucking...
Oh, my God.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's go.
Woo!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, God.
Leave me alone.
Leave me.
Boom.
Okay.
Please, leave me alone.
Leave me a...
That's it.
No more, Mr. Nice Monkey.
No!
Oh, wait, I got it.
I got it off.
I got it...
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
I fucking...
Okay.
We will get there, monkeys.
Did we do it?
Oh, we did it!
Oh, we fucking did it!
Holy shit!
How is he so strong?!
Absorb!
Absorb his ass right now!
Whorefrost.
Idling on the- Transforming into a monk from the sea.
Weaving strikes with a blizzard race and launching attacks that inflict frostbane.
Alright, which is stronger?
Wolf or frost?
I can't believe we did it.
We fucking did it.
Am I free?
What are they doing?
Farming trees?
Are they minecrafting?
The fuck are they doing here?
Like, are they minecrafting right now?
Wolf is stronger?
I knew it.
Wolf could never fail me.
Are they minecrafting?
What are they doing over there?
Hello guys.
Where do I go?
Wait, it's you.
Don't disturb their minecraft.
What the fuck?
Am I supposed to kill you?
I can't tell.
Are you- Oh, this is not fair!
There's- Oh, there's the faces!
It's not fair!
He has ha- Oh, fuck this.
I'm not fighting this.
F- Okay.
Alright, guess that he wants to fight me.
Okay.
You can't jump here!
Maybe you can, but like I'm not gonna risk it.
Hey guys.
Wow!
Wait, where am I?
Where the fuck did I go?
Like, I'm so lost!
Like, where did I go?
Okay, there's no way I can die here.
I'm literally 1 HP.
Not if I killed them first.
Oh no, not them.
Oh no.
Oh no, not the wolf.
I messed up.
It's okay.
I'm in this corner.
They can't find me in the corner.
You can't get me if I leave right now.
Pew!
No way.
I didn't know.
It's just that easy.
Nice.
I missed the good loot.
Oh, do I have to do this again?
Okay.
Guys, I just didn't want to die to moms.
Oh, hey.
I didn't see this chest.
What the fuck?
This was behind me this entire time.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We can do this again.
I know my way.
I know how to get there.
I needed...
Guys, I needed to recharge.
Oh, I can put the trap!
The trap?
Really?
Oh my god!
I can't!
Jesus Christ.
I could've done this the entire time.
Oh, I should upgrade actually.
Let me check.
What do I upgrade?
Uhhh...
Reduces...
I'll reduce that.
And then...
What is this?
Uhhh...
I want to do more immobilized stuff.
It consumes a moderate amount of...
To max it...
Mmm...
I don't...
I don't want that.
Okay.
Cloud step.
Uhhh...
Increases the mo...
Increases...
Each talent.
Wait, I should actually...
Wait, never mind.
I should get that.
Actually...
I don't care about that.
Uhhh...
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh.
What do I need to do here?
Oh, deal extra damage?
I like extra damage.
Alright.
We just...
We just need to walk all the way there.
We just gotta keep going.
Alright.
The good loot.
Wherever that good loot is, we'll get there.
Bro, I don't even know what my skill tree is.
My skill tree is just...
It works.
Like...
Hahaha...
If it works, it works.
Alright.
Captain Illusion from the Valley of Ecstasy?
The fuck do I...
Okay, we're gonna get...
How do I get there?
The good loot shit.
What if I just kill these monks?
Fuck their meditation.
He doesn't know where I am because he's blind.
Yeah, where am I?
Haha!
Whoa!
He barely takes any damage?
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I have electricity now.
I don't know how.
I wasn't paying attention to my skill tree.
Oh, he has the cold iron liens.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, where do we go?
We go up?
How do we get the...
Good...
The good shit.
The good loot.
Okay, I gotta get rid of this guy though.
It's fine.
He doesn't know I'm here.
Alright.
Get rid of him though.
What the fuck?
We can do that?
Alright.
Weapon time!
Wherever it is!
Wherever the weapon is!
Wait... Where?
Is it here?
Where did this go?
It's just a random tree.
Guys, I'll never be not lost.
Like... it's just...
It's just life at that point.
Wait.
There's nothing here.
He's just chilling.
He's literally just chilling.
What the?
Why did you tell me to go back here?
What the?!
You guys were like Doki go back you just missed a really good loot.
Yes Oh, hey I did oh I did it was just cold iron leaves it doesn't even matter
Doesn't even matter to me Fuck did you make me go back
Go back and fight which one Which one is the fucking Which electricity guy there's so many
Yay cold iron leaves my beloved
That's right That's right.
That's fucking right.
Electricity!
Whoa!
Maybe you should just take off that blindfold!
Alright.
It was not him.
He does not give me that helmet or whatever.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm going back.
I'm fucking going back.
Instant transmission.
Alright.
I must have good equipment now, right?
I know I've bumped into some.
Let me double check.
Equipment.
Nope.
All of them are garbage.
Nice.
That's good to know.
Alright, let's see.
Do I have better armor?
No, all my other armor is better already.
Okay.
Alright, that's good to know too.
Okay, Valley of Ecstasy.
Where is it?
Where do I go?
There's a lot of places.
I'm not fighting the tiger!
Not today!
Not today.
I'm not fighting the tiger.
He's already won too many fights.
He caused the PC explosion.
I'm not fighting him today.
We will fight him after we finish Chapter 3.
I'll fight him after Chapter 3.
The first goal is to beat Chapter 3.
Okay, where do I go here?
Fight Tommy the Tiger.
Which way?
Woah.
Where did you come from?
Oh, so it's the other side.
Okay.
It's this side.
Let me get rid of these.
Woah!
He was pretending!
But like, actually pretending!
Jesus Christ, come on.
Leave me alone, man.
Oh!
There you go.
It's not my dog.
Did you guys hear that?
You guys don't hear that?
I'm gonna check on him.
What the fuck was that?
He's like...
Oh my
God!
Wait, did you guys hear that?
What?
He was like howling!
I've never heard that before!
I've never heard him howl like that before!
He was like...
Oh!
I was like...
What the...
Like, I've never heard that specific howl!
Like...
This is the first time...
It was the first time I've ever heard him howl like that.
Woah!
And then, like, when I went to check on him...
He, like, just...
He fucking...
He fucking just jumped down.
Like, I couldn't even see what he was doing.
He literally just jumped down from his bed and just, like, met me at the door.
Like, he's never done that before.
So I was like, what the fuck?
Are you okay?
Like...
He's like...
Not even when we first moved!
He was so...
Oh my god, I was just so surprised!
Am I at the right place?
Like...
I don't even know where I am anymore.
Wait, have I been here?
I've not been here before.
Where am I?
Oh, go back to the shrine.
Okay.
Like, what...
What happened?
Literally one day!
Like, what happened to him?
All it took was one day for him to fucking go back to his roots.
Wait, why is there a crow here?
Usually they're like...
Like, they never appear back after you kill them.
So I'm just like, what are you doing here?
He missed...
He's like, back to WoW.
I was not ignoring.
Wait, where the fuck is the...
I already lost track of the shrine.
Already...
Wait, no, not this.
No!
My one item!
It's over.
I used...
I used an item!
This run is dead!
The run is dead!
Is it this way?
Wait, so where do I go?
Restart the run?
Oh, this way.
We got to restart now.
Guys, the run is dead.
The run is dead.
Our zero item is dead.
Item run, it's over.
It's fucking over.
We're supposed to do no items.
Back to chapter one.
Jesus Christ, this guy took way too long.
Am I going the right way?
Oh hey, there's will though.
Even if I'm not, there's willpower.
Poke!
Will.
Okay nice, that's an extra 720.
Okay, should be around here.
Alright, that's good to know.
Get rid of these guys.
I want them outta here!
In front of me like this?
Holy shit, that's a big ass bird.
Yoink, mine now.
Yoink, what the fuck is he?
Ow!
Oh, that's the guy I killed earlier!
Oh, that's him!
I was like, who the f- What the fuck is this guy?
Oh yeah, I killed him!
I just left his body to fucking rot, I guess.
Cliff, and then I just left him to rot.
Alright.
Well, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, Willy.
Did you know the green spirit regens one gourd use?
Blue and purple fully restores, recharges gourd.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Time to...
Now I just need to...
Uh...
Go back to...
Oh shit, no.
Oh, I do need to rest too, as well.
Good.
Pagoda.
There we go.
This guy.
To show him that I killed all his friends.
All his ex-friends.
They're not his friends anymore.
Don't worry, sir.
All your ex-friends are dead now.
They didn't deserve you.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, he's like all the way back there.
Polly, thank you for the 10.
Get the shivs.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, off we go.
We're off to see the wizard.
The wonderful wizard of Oz.
It's like here, right?
Is this where you live?
No.
Is this?
Oh no, that is where he lives.
Alright.
Oh shit, don't worry.
I got this.
Get out.
I'm already strong.
Thank you for bringing them back.
You don't have to suffer the pain of being a demon anymore.
I left home when I was a kid.
And I had to go back to heaven.
But now...
It's like this.
What's wrong with you?
You can't even get along with my brothers.
You just have red eyes.
I'm not a freak.
This is useless to me.
The cops like it.
Just take it.
What the fuck is that?
Thanks for the gift, emo boy.
I'm just monkey.
The third prince.
Oh, he's the third prince.
Oh, you're crazy.
Oh, you can't see and you're deaf.
Oh, maybe I should have done what you told me to do.
Why did I... I don't know, I didn't listen to a crazy guy.
Bros got all on the nerve.
Yeah, he said he's going home.
He said I'm going to go home.
Oh, whoops.
Alright.
I don't know if I should have done what he told me to do now that I realize he's crazy, deaf, and blind.
I just know he can still feel vibrations.
He could feel like somebody's foot there.
He could feel the monkey.
Alright, craft.
Can I craft this thing?
Ooh!
75.
Wait, that's a lot.
That's more.
Nice.
Ooh, wait.
My stick has a pointy thing now.
I finally learned to add a fucking sword... like a knife to my stick.
Alright, now where do I go?
Where's... now I have... I finally have a pointy stick.
Wait, where's the melon?
I got the stabby stab.
Stabby stab!
No, we gotta get the melon!
Forest of Felicity.
Okay.
Felicity and then run down.
Those seems like... those seems like easy instructions.
How hard can it be?
This way.
Down.
Is this down?
That's up.
Wait, but where's...
Down!
This is down.
Oh!
I'm looking at my directions!
This is down.
Down is up!
Exactly!
Have you never heard of that before?
Okay, this is down.
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay, that's a lot.
That's a lot of stabby stabby.
Okay.
Oh, I like how like you can hear the different sound effects cause now there's like a knife...
Finally, I learned.
I've like mastered the Iron Age.
So like...
Monkey has mastered the Iron Age.
And now monkey can...
Can make knife.
I've been here before.
Oh, wait.
No, I have...
Wait, what?
Follow the water?
Water where?
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, monkey can shank now.
Is this water?
Follow the water.
Water follow.
I'm following water.
Monkey make knife.
Monkey can now stab.
Stabby stab!
Wait, who's he?
Oh, he's a summon!
Bakro!
That's fucking right.
I can stab now!
That's fucking right!
Fire!
Monkey will learn how to gun soon.
Ha ha ha ha!
If monkey can learn how to stab.
Monkey will learn how to fight...
How to gun.
We're almost there.
Absorb.
Alright, nice.
We got the...
We got a spirit that we'll never use.
Why give me fucking baby if that's like the only...
Ha ha ha!
Their first mistake is giving me the most powerful spirit.
Summon in the beginning of the game.
Ha ha ha ha!
That was their first mistake.
Now that's the only thing I use.
I follow water.
When does water end?
Oh, frog.
That's right, frog.
I'll beat you up.
Your king's dead.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta make sure this other frog is dead too.
Goodbye.
I follow water.
Where go now?
Ha ha ha ha!
Where monkey go?
Oh, hey.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this place?
Well, that's a lot of absorb.
Oh, jump down.
Oh, here?
Okay.
Let's rid of him first.
Bye.
Alright.
Trust fall.
Yay!
Trust fall?
Oh.
Oh, we go down here.
Okay.
I was willing to fall even more.
I trust you guys.
Okay.
And then down here.
Oh, there's an incense.
Nice.
Yeah, I got a whole new move set.
Because I can finally shank.
Because monkey shank.
I guess into the pit.
This looks like a boss fight.
Did the melon quest tricked me into a boss fight?
No.
I was like, okay, I have to do this.
And then dad stops howling!
Why are all these fetch quests our boss fights in the end?
When can they actually boss fight?
When are they actually fetch quests?
Damn.
Look at this guy's thighs.
Hey, what are you?
I got a really bad luck, why?
I didn't have a chance to watch the video.
I swear.
I'm sorry.
I mean, I'm sorry...
that I had to do the theory test.
Wait!
Was he the guy that was like, I'm cold?
You were not cold!
You had the power of fire this entire time!
You weren't even cold!
You made me waste magic!
I can't believe it!
He wasn't even cold!
Bro!
That's fucked!
You weren't even cold in the first place!
That's so fucked!
How could you lie to me about that?
I swapped my magic for you, you bitch!
I never swapped magic!
I broke my magic for you!
You weren't even cold!
You're not even a man!
Oh my god!
What else have you lied to me about?
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Stop trapping me!
Bro!
Holy shit!
What do I do with all these wheels?
What do I do?
There's so many wheels!
Wow!
It's all wheels!
Not cool, bro!
I thought we could be best friends, bro!
I thought we could be homies, bro!
Bro, what the fuck?
That's not cool!
It's not cool!
I can't believe you would trick me like that!
Wait, what?
How did I miss?
What the fuck?
Oh no.
Bro, not cool, bro.
Not cool.
What the fuck?
You literally have spinning wheels!
You are doing more tricks than me!
That's fucking right.
You interrupted, bitch.
Oh fuck, never mind.
He interrupted my combo too.
What?
Let me heal.
It's not fair.
What if I just do this?
It does nothing.
It's the thought that counts, you know?
Doesn't matter.
That's fucking right!
A quirky man.
I like how that's his description.
Your brother?
Your brother called for my hit?
Thank god I got the shank.
I think I wouldn't have been able to do it, but...
Oh!
I brought back the grass!
I did it.
Grass shall return now.
He played with portals.
Wait!
There's melons!
There is melons!
He did it!
Does that mean there's no more snow?
Oh my god,
it's your melons!
Melons!
The fuck?
That's a strong ass baby.
That's a fucking strong ass baby!
Yeah!
Oh?
What trick?
Of course I'm not going to trust this random baby.
Oh?
What did he do?
Find spells, vessels, transformation, and soul skills.
To enhance attack focusing solely on martial arts.
What spell is that?
Where does it go?
He gave me baby queens.
Yeah, but what does it replace?
The Great Pagoda?
Oh, it takes my transformations?
It locks your spell to go full melee.
Okay.
You can't, but you hit so much.
All right, we'll try it out.
I guess we could try it out.
All right.
We have to go to the Great Pagoda?
Where the fuck is that?
How do we get to the Great Pagoda?
Bunga bunga.
All right, let's see.
Spells.
Set spells.
I guess it's this?
No?
Oh!
Okay.
By slapping rain on a palm, it constrains senses when active.
Binding the use of any and solo when comfortable.
Cable cap restricting this spell may offer an unexpected effect.
Oh, you go down to find all the secret areas.
Wait, what are all the secret areas?
Let's see.
Does it use all of it?
Can I like... wait, let me check it.
How much does it cost?
310.
That's all my spell points, right?
Oh, so I have to do four and five.
Okay, I have to do chapter four and five before I can go back to the Great Pagoda.
Okay.
Okay, how do I get to the final boss?
Where's the final boss?
Also, unlock this.
And I don't know what to do.
Wait, no.
Oh, and yeah, that's the Great Pagoda.
Unlock this.
I found this.
There it is.
Back to the temple.
Okay.
Straight all the way.
All the way.
Is there like an incense area for it?
Oh my god, guys.
Guys, I can't believe we're gonna see what the final... what the end of chapter three is gonna be.
We're actually... holy shit.
It's been three hours.
We're gonna see the end of chapter three.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god, guys.
We're actually...
holy shit.
It's been three hours.
We're gonna see the end of chapter three.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
It's been twenty years.
We're gonna leave Snowland.
I heard chapter three is literally like the...
Oh my god.
It's like the heart... the longest chapter out of everything.
So like chapter four and five, six will not be as long.
It took me so long.
But we're getting there.
Is chapter five longer?
Wait, chapter four is even longer?
Was I lied to?
I thought three was the longest.
Wait, what?
I literally...
Literally you guys told me chapter three was the longest.
No!
Oh no.
Wait, why is there two big babies?
Why is there two of you?
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Should I be fighting you guys?
Alright, I'm not.
I'm gonna ignore you guys.
No, I'm gonna...
Okay.
I guess he doesn't want me to ignore you guys.
But you can't stop me.
I can't...
I can't read.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Can't walk up...
Oh.
That's a dead end.
Guys.
He can't walk up the stairs.
He can't walk up the stairs, guys.
He can't...
Oh, there was a stripe behind me.
I didn't even notice.
I guess I have to walk through that again.
Oh, baby.
Baby.
Are you evil, baby?
I thought you were the Buddha.
Wait, that's a different baby?
How many babies are in the world?
Yellow baby equals evil baby?
Oh, you sound like an evil baby.
You sound like a very angry...
Somebody's past your bedtime.
Baby, are you past your bedtime?
He was not baby.
Oh, you're not a baby.
Oh!
You are definitely not a baby.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, now I know what that is.
There we go, we got it.
Okay.
Alright, I have to figure out what your moves are.
I need to figure out what your moves are.
I'm so confused.
Oh, shit!
Oh, what?
Okay, he disappeared anyway.
What is he doing?
Yes!
Interrupts your moment.
I didn't know what he was doing.
I'm just as confused.
I didn't know he was monologuing.
I was like, what is he doing?
So rude.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
I'm just trying to fight.
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
What did he do?
What was that?
Is that their creation?
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
Oh, shit!
THAT STILL HITS ME?!
Oh my god, okay.
Oh no.
Okay.
No!
I'm so confused!
Oh my god, his movesets are so confusing!
Baby smash!
I'm panicked!
NOOOOOO!
Oh my god, I was so confused!
I was like, what is he- oh no, the water's all the way back!
Oh my god!
I was- what- oh my god, I could've first tried him too!
I could've first tried him if I wasn't so confused!
Oh my god!
He was so- oh my god, it literally was so easy!
Literally, I could've just fucking instantly killed him.
Okay, I can do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, he's so easy!
He was actually so easy!
I was just confused!
Alright.
I was just confused with his moveset because sometimes he- WHAT THE FUCK?!
Okay.
But sometimes I didn't do anything because I was like, what do I do?
Like, what is he doing?
Alright.
Up we go.
We're gonna get to the shrine.
Yeah, he's so sluggish.
His timing was so weird.
I didn't understand the timing too.
Okay, where's the shrine?
Should be here somewhere, right?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god, it was so far away.
I'm blind.
Look, it's white!
On white!
It's snow on snow!
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Oh hey, there's a will here.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, 1200?
That's a lot.
That's actually a lot.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Alright, here we go again.
I like how he's just chilling.
Like how he's just...
He's just watching me.
He's just like, hey.
I'm like, hey.
Hey to you too.
Okay, now I know what that...
Whoa!
Okay, recharge.
Recharge.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, big baby tripped.
Big baby tripped!
That's fucking right!
Get tripped!
Okay.
This is the hard part.
When he does all of that shit.
Like...
Oh!
Okay, I can only get one hit in.
Okay.
Like, I don't...
I don't know what... I don't know what this is.
Like...
Okay.
What is he doing?
He does that?
Okay.
What does... What is that?
Alright.
Oh!
I ran out of stamina.
I ran out of stamina!
No!
I ran out of stamina.
I ran out of stamina!
I greeted!
I couldn't dodge!
Oh my god!
I couldn't...
I got greedy!
I got greedy and I couldn't dodge because I ran out of stamina.
No!
NOOOOOO!
That would have been so easy too!
Okay.
Oh shit, not okay.
Guys, it was not okay, guys.
I fucked up.
It was definitely not okay.
Okay.
Fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
Sam!
Oh, that still hits me?
NOOOOO!
That still...
That's a grab?!
Let go of me!
Let me go!
I can't grapple.
If I didn't get stunned!
If I didn't lose my stamina on the second run, it would have been so easy.
Cookie, I got grappled.
I must have some!
Oh, I do.
Thank god.
I was gonna say.
I must have some.
Removes all four.
Recovers a concern after successfully performing.
Okay.
Okay, we'll do that.
Oh...
Oh my god, I got grappled.
I got karma'd.
I got grappled.
Stupid man-baby.
Jesus.
Stupid fucking man-baby.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
I'm gonna stab you.
Stupid fucking man-baby.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna stab you.
NOOOOO!
Okay, I know what that does now.
Poke!
That's fucking right, man-baby.
Get your ass poked.
Get your ass poked!
Poke!
And I'll keep doing it too.
Okay.
Alright, stamina, stamina, stamina.
Oh, okay, goodbye.
Where did he TP to?
Oh, I still don't know what that does.
I'm just gonna do this for you.
And then... do that?
I don't know.
Okay.
I know now.
Now.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Okay, you do that.
I found out.
Oh shit!
I fucked around- WHAT?!
Oh my god.
Okay...
I found out...
Max out spellbinding?
Okay...
Alright, but doesn't it re- Does...
Reignite?
No, okay.
Uhhhh...
I guess...
Wait...
I guess I get rid of this?
Guys, I don't remember what I got, so this is gonna be fun.
This is gonna be fun.
Okay, let's figure this out.
Okay.
And then, we'll put it all on this.
Nice.
Okay, I don't know what I did, so this is gonna be very fun.
This is gonna be so fun.
Alright, nice.
No think, only bonk.
Alright.
Here we go.
We'll figure it out together, guys.
We're gonna figure it out together.
Oh, I...
Guys, I fucked up.
I fucked up already.
I need to end the match.
I already fucked up my first.
I already...
I already fucked up.
I can't eat anything.
I accidentally pressed 2.
No, you're supposed to end me.
What the fuck?
Please.
Please stop talking.
Oh, now...
Oh, now you're gonna talk.
Oh my god, bro.
Bro, come on.
Now he wants to talk.
This is actually crazy.
Okay, this time...
This time we can do it.
Okay.
That doesn't count!
That's not...
That does not count.
I lost...
I fucked up my...
I fucked up my spell casting.
That doesn't count, guys.
Guys, I fucked up my spellcasting chat.
That does not fucking count.
That does not count.
I messed it up.
I pressed 2.
I just let him hit me.
What the fuck?
Now he doesn't let me hit him.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Fuck.
Okay.
Alright, he can do that.
And I can do that.
And then I can do that.
And then I can be like...
Oh shit.
Okay.
That's not cool.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Nope.
We are not getting it.
You're not getting me this time.
That's fine.
Okay.
Stumble again, bitch.
Stamina recharge.
Oh no.
Not this move.
Okay.
I'm not risking this move.
I'm not risking that move, man.
This move is fucked.
Bro I'm not trusting myself against that.
What???
That still hits me?
Okay.
Fuck off.
What???
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, that's also fine.
Is this scripted?
Oh, what?
Oh, that's scripted.
Oh, thank god, that's scripted.
Thank god, that's actually scripted.
Okay, that's gonna be like, that's so bullshit.
Oh my god, she's so angry if it was not scripted.
Where am I?
Get into the sack.
I don't like that he's just watching me like that.
Fucking freak.
Monkey is stored in the sack.
What's going on?
Wait, Pigsy?
Chewbacca!
What are you doing here?
Wait, you got trapped too?
Look chat, Doki went inside.
Oh, no!
He sucked.
Thank you, Mr. Pigsy.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, we're both, we both got caught.
Wait, is that my sack?
Yeah, I was gonna say, this is Wukong's sack.
Oh no, he has wings again.
Okay, it's fine.
It's two against one.
Oh, it might not be fine though.
Oh, it might not be fine.
I'm gonna drink this just in case.
Chewbacca, hit him for me!
Nice.
He's helping.
Oh god, you're supposed to help me even more!
Oh no, okay.
It's fine.
No!
It's not fine!
No, it's not fine!
It's not!
Heal me!
Heal me, pig!
Which one's the real one?
No!
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Oh, am I gonna die?
I'm gonna die!
No!
It's too much!
I have to do it again!
I have to do this fight again!
I have to do phase one again!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I had to go back into the side!
I had to get into the side.
I had to fucking...
Fight the fucking man-baby again!
Just absorb me in the sack right now!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Thank god!
I'm so happy!
Oh my god!
I'm okay with this!
I'm okay!
Yes!
He instantly transported me into the sack!
I fucked up though!
I used my magic!
It's okay!
I wanted to die because I fucked up!
You heal too late, pigsy!
You heal too late!
Alright!
Accident press 2!
Galix thank you for the super chat!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
Did you just call him a pig?
How dare you!
I bet there are plenty of spiders who want to marry him!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
There's nothing wrong with being a pig!
There's nothing wrong!
Okay.
There's nothing!
If a spider wants to bang a pig, let her bang a pig!
Oh!
My god!
Oh shit!
Did I use it?
Oh my god!
Are you really serious?
He interrupted it!
He actually interrupted it!
This little fucker!
I can't believe it.
He actually interrupted my post.
That's so fucked.
That's so actually fucked, man.
It's not a skill issue!
You fucking cheated!
I refuse to believe it's a skill issue!
Oh my god.
No, not the shadow jutsu.
Oh my god, this is hell!
This is hell!
Oh my god, there's too many...
There's too many monkeys!
Too many monkeys!
What?!
That should not have hit me.
That was actually bullshit.
Oh god.
Oh my god, bro.
He's so...
He's so scary.
Oh fuck, bro.
He actually interrupted it again.
Are you fucking serious?
I...
He's so fast.
Why did he put him in the pouch?
Okay.
Wait, can I use it before the fight?
Can I actually do that?
Okay.
Use it outside?
Oh my god I'm gonna use it outside.
Dude fuck this.
Fuck that fucking monkey.
I hate that monkey so much.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
Guys, he's so strong.
My god, you lied to me!
I have to use it here!
I CAN'T JUST USE IT OUTSIDE!
Wait, how does that hurt me?
What?
Okay, nice.
WHOA!
Okay, that's a lot of damage.
For the poke?
Holy shit!
Okay.
OH!
THE SHADOW CLOUDS!
THE FUCKING SHADOW CLOUDS!
Oh god, no.
Oh god.
Okay.
That's fine.
Poke!
Okay, I wanted to get that in first.
Before he does anything else.
Okay.
What is he doing?
Wait, what is he doing?
Wait, did he heal?
I don't know.
Holy shit!
Please, Pixie, help me!
Please!
Thank you, Pixie!
Oh my god, first!
Oh thank god!
Oh no!
Nothing good!
Okay, Pixie, your turn!
Your turn!
No!
Pixie, it's your turn!
Please, it's your turn!
He's literally right there!
WHOA!
Oh god.
Okay.
Please!
Please be involved!
That's all I ask you!
Please!
Please, just hit him!
He's literally right there!
Just hit him!
Died!
He got the last hit!
Oh my god!
He actually hit him!
Finally!
You did it when it matters!
Salve!
That's right!
I'm the stronger monkey!
What am I doing?
Why am I hesitating?
Do it!
Oh, you did it!
I am the true monkey!
Huh?
That's the point, right?
What the?
Huh?
Wait, am I the crazy monkey now?
The sword?
Am I evil monkey?
No...
I'm crazy monkey... I'm wind ball!
The crazier I get, the less hair I have!
Something says I should just run.
Oh my god!
Look at me!
I went full monkey!
I'm full monkey!
Oh!
I'm monkey!
Get me out of here!
Never go full monkey!
No, not the light!
Monkey doesn't want light!
Get out!
Monkey...
Don't kill?
What happens when I kill?
Do I turn crazy?
Oh no, I already killed.
Instructions unclear.
I stabbed a few.
I accidentally stabbed a few.
Too late now.
I didn't know I was supposed...
I didn't know I was supposed to stab!
Oh sh....
I... I stabbed...
It's too late now!
No!
Don't say it!
Don't say the reset!
Don't...
Don't say that, guys!
Please!
I didn't...
I...
It's okay.
It's okay, I died.
I purposely died, so... I purposely died, so I don't... I purposely died, guys!
So, like, I didn't... yeah!
There we go!
Wait!
Oh no!
I'm here!
Don't!
You have to be fucking with me!
There's no way!
I refuse to believe you're fucking with me!
You have to be fucking with me!
Oh no!
There's no way!
I don't believe in him!
No, it can't be true!
It can't be true!
They were evil first!
It was self-defense!
We all know it was self-defense!
You all saw it!
Oh no!
What the fuck did he do to me?
But he's evil!
What?
Oh my god!
Monkey's sad!
Okay.
What the fuck?
What am I getting?
Ring of electricity!
What the fuck is this bullshit?
This is a bullshit boss fight.
I hate this boss fight.
I... I...
Oh, someone said I just need to do that.
Nice.
Okay.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Get this guy away from me.
Get him away.
Woo!
Okay.
Wow!
Get out.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll keep the... I'll keep the... the three points.
No, no.
Oh, no.
Not again.
No!
I hate this man.
Oh my god.
Now where am I going?
Now he has another combo?
This is absolutely bullshit.
You should not be allowed three different fucking combos.
Like...
Like, why does he get all of that?
Okay.
That's fine.
That is fine.
Turn god!
Turn god, you fucker!
I'm ready for you!
What?
That hit me?
Okay.
That's fucked.
Oh shit!
That's fucked too.
Alright.
Come on!
Turn god!
Turn fucking god!
Jesus Christ.
That's fucking right!
I have this!
Boom!
Just for when you turn god!
That's fucking right!
Turn god again!
Ganderia!
Fuck you!
Come on!
I could have seen your end.
As long as you keep fighting for others, you will die in their hands sooner or later.
Or yourself?
That's greedy.
That's not the Buddha way.
Oh, it's him.
It's Man Bird.
Phase 5?
What do you mean Phase 5?
We're going to turn into Iceman now?
Iceman baby?
Oh, there's no way.
Where did you come from?
Good Buddha?
,
,,
Oh, you pretended to fake... Bro, you just slapped the Buddha.
,
,,
Yeah!
I'm the chosen one!
,
Isn't that the really?
What is he doing?
What is he gonna fish?
Am I gonna fucking fight a fish?
What the fuck?
Am I gonna fight him?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I'm not.
It's animation time.
Oh, it's a new style.
It's a new animation style.
Oh, thank God it was over.
Okay, so, what the fuck?
Is that him?
Is that the...
The dead?
Oh, no.
No, that's somebody else.
Is he gonna give birth?
Oh.
Easy.
It's like a...
Let me sneeze on you and then you can be beautiful.
Yeah, it's a softshell turtle.
Oh, and then the city prospered because of him.
He became like a god.
He provide like diamonds and pearls.
I feel like he could be a demon.
A Yaoguai.
And not like an actual...
...Yeti.
Or is he...
Oh?
What's going on?
He's gonna kill him out of greed!
Oh!
Out of greed!
What the fuck?
The corruption...
No!
Oh, my God!
I said...
Oh!
Oh, my God!
No!
He's gonna die.
What the fuck!
And then they lost their unlimited money.
That's so fucked.
Yeah, like how do you...
Of course, they lost their unlimited source of money.
How could they like...
Oh my god.
For your life?
It's so funny.
It's so sad.
Yeah, isn't that Xifu?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That's Xifu.
Oh, so he was trying to prove, like, a point.
That...
That, like, humans will always be greedy.
Yeah.
Well, that was Yellow Brow?
Okay, so, like, why couldn't I hit the Buddhas?
Were you gaslighting me?
Did you?
Were you?
You guys, you fuckers.
You fucking...
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew you guys were fucking gaslighting me.
Oh my god.
That's so fucked.
I purposely lost.
I purposely died because I was like, Oh no, I fucking killed them.
Maybe I'll reset it.
Maybe I'll just reset it.
You fuckers.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, there's Normal Baby.
I'm not... Okay.
I'm not...
Okay.
I'm not... Okay.
We learned from the best.
JL, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We finally did it.
Oh, hey, there's more.
Oh, there's these guys.
Oh, there's Tiger Boy.
Oh,
there's these guys.
Oh, there's Tiger Boy.
Oh, a gong?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's the zodiacs.
Oh yeah, the snake general.
His roommate's dead.
The turtle's roommate's dead.
What about this guy?
Who's this guy?
Oh, is that the flying, deaf, and crazy guy?
Oh, it is!
Flying, deaf, and crazy.
That's me.
That's everybody, right?
Everybody?
Alright, next chapter.
Yes.
I wanna know what the next chapter's gonna be like.
Then maybe we'll fight Tommy the Tiger.
Maybe.
We'll see how I feel after this.
After chapter... after intro of chapter four.
We'll see how I feel.
Huh?
Hurry up.
Oh my god, who's... what is that?
Woah!
That's gonna be me?
I'm still in your dreams.
Wanna see what happened.
I'm still in your dreams too.
Woah.
I'm in your dreams too.
Alright, we're getting ready.
We're gonna finish this.
A quick sneak peek.
I'm not gonna lie to you anymore.
I'm very skilled at doing this.
I've been doing this for a very long time.
Okay, let's just do this.
Bye.
I'll see you next time.
See ya.
What?
What's that?
I'm trying to... what?
Oh, she's joining me in the journey?
He's still there?
Oh, I thought it was...
I thought it was Wukong in there.
Wukong, come down and talk to me.
He's gone.
Oh, he was with me!
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, he was with me.
Okay.
Alright.
I was like...
Oh, I thought...
I was like, where the fuck is Wukong?
Okay, where's the incense?
Like...
Where am I?
Okay, at least it's trees now.
It's no more snow.
Is that the hag?
Is that her?
Wait, where's the incense?
What the fuck?
Okay, I guess I'll just grab some materials then.
For now.
Give me a sec, Pigsy.
I'm trying to...
What is he doing?
I'm trying to loot.
Loot is important.
Wait, what's up here?
What's up here?
Absorb.
Okay, we gotta find...
We have to find... we have to find the incense area so we can head, uh, we can save our game.
Oh hey, mushroom.
Nice.
Mushroom that I'll never use.
All right, let's see.
Let's go this way.
All right.
Go this way.
The shrine is inside?
Like, deeper into the area?
Like here?
I assume it's there.
That's like literally the only way to go.
Wait, what's that up there?
You see that?
Is that an enemy?
Oh yeah, it is.
It's like, what's that hang up there?
Hello!
The village.
What is he?
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Is that Spider?
Oh shit, it is.
Bro he's so ugly!
Bro, what the fuck?
You can't just call him ugly like that.
Well like, tough love.
Like, I'm not gonna lie to him.
I'm not gonna lie.
So many like...
Oh, there's another one.
There's so many spiders.
Hell yeah.
Alright.
Alright, off we go.
Oh, there's flies now too?
What the fuck?
I thought it was a...
Oh shit.
Wait, you're not a spider?
Wait, what the fuck?
You're not a...
Wait, what are you?
You're not a spider.
You're an Oni.
Wait, no.
Oni is like Japanese.
Wait, what are you?
There's a lantern.
Okay, he's just holding...
Okay.
I was like, what are you?
He just holds the lantern, guys.
He's just...
Okay.
He's just there to hold the lantern, I guess.
I guess that...
He's just...
I guess that's his name.
Doesn't even have an actual real name.
He's just...
Lantern holding.
Oh yeah, he's illuminating the path for all the other guys.
He's just an employee.
He's a street light.
Oh, what are you?
Is he a mouse?
Are you a cockroach?
What are you?
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
I might as well.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got this.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
I think he's a cockroach.
Let's see, what are you?
He is a beetle captain!
I was very wrong!
Alright.
He's just a beetle captain.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Poke!
Alright.
Like, at least he has a name, you know?
Like, he has a job.
Like, he has a captain.
And he's like...
It tells you what he is.
That guy just fucking holds lanterns.
There you go.
Poor man.
You're warning if you hate bugs.
Yeah, this isn't...
This is bug...
This is bug county right here.
Okay.
This is bug county.
Abzor.
Alright.
Mail number!
It's like in gacha games.
What was that gacha game?
There was a gacha game that's...
That's literally like, has like three mail characters.
And one of them doesn't even have a name.
I don't remember.
I'm trying to remember!
I don't remember...
I don't remember which gacha game that was.
That's...
I'm going to try to remember.
What was that?
There's like a wikipedia page of the characters in this gacha game.
And literally the male characters is just like...
One is like male unnamed male or some shit.
I was like damn that's fucking rough.
That's fucking rough.
Wait he dodged that?
How?
That's way too big.
Oh is that a shrine?
Bro where the fuck am I?
Where the fuck is the shrine?
All I see is the light.
Oh my god.
All I see is the employees.
That's just trying to fucking hold the light.
Get out of here.
Get out of my fucking video game.
Poke.
Alright.
Oh wait that's poison.
Okay.
Oh it's you.
You fucker.
Garrett thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's not true Garrett.
I know this is not your first time.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
First time super chatting.
You're a great streamer.
I'm not normally watching vtubers but I found your channel.
You deserve all the praise.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah Garrett where's the first time super chat?
How does she know?
Youtube snitched on you Garrett.
I know.
He got snitched on.
I like how other chatters are like I saw you here before.
That's fun.
Fuck.
That's actually fucked.
Alright let's put this on.
Alright confirm.
Oh my god I can finally have better armor too.
Confirm.
Okay.
Yes please.
I don't have fine gold thread?
How the fuck do I?
Can I buy that?
Okay buy.
Oh I can thank god.
Okay.
Two.
I can sell all my shit.
I have like so much shit I didn't sell.
Alright nice.
Okay craft.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my god I'm fucking rich.
Look at me.
Now I have chill resistance.
Finally.
Alright.
We're gonna rest.
And then we're gonna do the stupid tiger man.
Come on.
We're gonna do it.
That set bonus is anti melee.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Don't give me anti chill when I'm like there.
You know?
Okay let's make sure.
Let's just make sure.
What was it?
Visual effect.
Let's put visual effect on low.
Because that shit killed my PC.
And it never fixed itself after that.
Was it visual effect?
It was visual effect right?
Or was it post effect quality?
Was it?
I don't remember.
Um.
Is it post effect or just visual effect?
Both?
Okay.
I'm not risking it.
Like this tiger.
This tiger fucked me up.
This tiger.
Oh my god.
Oh it's this area.
It's this area.
Oh my god.
It's not even.
It's this area.
It's actually this area.
Holy shit.
Oh my god bro.
Tiger gets all lows dude.
Fuck.
This is all lows.
Tiger gets all lows.
Like I can't.
Like oh my god.
I can't.
I have.
He doesn't deserve.
He doesn't deserve better quality.
Oh my god.
Look how low quality.
This area is so fucked.
I can't the game quality.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
The game quality is actually crazy.
Literally is this area.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was a big slap.
Come on, get over here.
Let's fucking... No way!
You fucking... Oh my god.
Wukong mobile.
This is Wukong mobile right now.
Where did he go?
What?!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh my god!
He fucking... I'm off my groove!
Oh my god.
I'm off my groove.
I'm off my groove now.
I'm off my groove!
Shit, I hate him so much.
Oh my god.
He's so annoying.
He's so annoying!
Okay.
Wukong!
I don't know his patterns!
Okay.
Oh shit!
I don't have a lot of heals now.
Okay.
My groove got so ruined.
Oh my god.
My whole timing was off too.
That's the worst part.
No!
Oh!
Oh god, no!
Okay.
Oh, you serious?!
My attack didn't hit first?!
That's fucked.
My attack should have hit first there.
Are you fucking...
Wait, did I do it?
Wait, I killed him?!
I skipped it!
I skipped it, guys!
I thought I lost!
Oh my god!
Bro!
The second...
Oh shit!
Hey!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is he equipped for, Kyrios?
Low quality.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I literally thought I lost.
I actually thought I lost.
Oh my god.
Oh thank god.
Thank god I don't have to keep going.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's this area.
This area is fucking so...
I don't know what is wrong with this area, but this area is fucked up, man.
Alright.
Monkey.
Do I have upgrades?
Long quality give you emotional damage.
Oh my god.
It's over.
Fuck.
Okay, let's upgrade.
Alright, what do we want to upgrade?
We have some Moncores.
Talk to the dog.
Alright.
Request medicine?
Oh yeah!
Give me your shit.
What are you giving me?
Okay.
Alright.
What do we want, guys?
Mana?
Does that actually do that?
Do we want mana or stamina?
Mana?
Okay, I can do mana.
Oh my god.
No, we don't care about the casino.
I think it's over.
We don't care.
It's over, guys.
You don't care.
I don't care.
We don't have to care.
Alright.
Do we get stamina recovery rate?
Or should I save for maximum stamina?
Actually, I'll get stamina recovery.
What do you get?
Save?
Okay.
Okay, we'll save.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Where is the...
Where the fuck is the shrine?
There it is.
Okay.
We go travel.
Web Hollow.
Oh yeah, it's definitely a spider queen.
Alright, let's change the quality back up to...
Let's put the quality back up.
Okay, please.
You're always running out of stamina.
Yet here you are investing in the stamina.
Here you are not investing in the stamina.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe it'll be different.
You don't know that.
Maybe...
Maybe it'll be different.
It could be different, guys.
Alright, we'll get that.
And then we'll put the graphics back.
Okay.
It's like high and then shadow is medium.
And vegetation... Was vegetation medium?
I don't remember.
Or was it low?
I actually don't remember what we put.
Alright, what was our settings, guys?
I don't remember.
Was it lower?
Veg was medium.
No grass.
No what?
No shadows.
You're right.
We don't fucking need shadows.
But like, the grass though.
The grass.
Don't you guys want good grass?
What about the grass?
Is there only chance?
Guys...
Oh my god, that's so ugly.
Let me...
Guys, but what about the grass?
The koosa.
I mean, it's still ugly.
Okay, I'm putting the shadows back to medium.
Alright, here we go.
I think that was what it was.
There we go.
It looks a little better now.
It looks...
It looks a little better.
Alright, we're gonna call it here.
We're gonna call it here, everybody.
Hey, don't trust outsiders to laugh at you.
Oh, I mean, we made it up.
We finally finished chapter three and that's all that matters to me.
Let's...
Oh my god, we finally...
We finally finished chapter three.
Let's hope...
Let's hope we can finish chapter...
Let's hope that chapter four is not as long.
Guys, let's...
Um...
Oh my god, let...
Let's hope...
Oh my god.
Oh, that was fun though.
I had a lot of fun.
I was...
I definitely very much enjoy Wukong.
So, like, I hope you guys have been enjoying Wukong as well.
And yeah, it's been a great time playing it.
I've been enjoying the story and the gameplay and the fights and everything.
So, I don't even know when I'll ever...
I hope I can finish this game soon.
It's a very long game.
But as long as I'm enjoying myself, that's all that matters.
Um...
Yeah.
Also, you guys didn't see.
You guys didn't see.
I announced a Bandai sponsor for their new game.
It's for their new game, Senuality.
I think that's how you pronounce it.
I'll be doing a stream on September 14th of the new game.
There's gonna be future announcements as well about it.
So, yeah.
Look forward to that.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm tired.
I did two streams today.
So, like...
I am gonna rest now.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.